Oh shit, hello everybody, I forgot, hello, hello everyone,
oh I forgot to do this, I'm sorry, I'm tired, I'm trying to
fix my sleep schedule, I'm trying very slowly to fix my
sleep schedule, wait, give me a sec, manager, message me and
it deleted the message, so I'm like, what is this, what, did
you a message?
I see like it popped up but then I didn't even I didn't see
the message because I had to refill my water so I had to
push the stream 30 minutes up because I was trying to fix my
sleep schedule but my body my body was not okay with that
plan my brain was also not okay with that plan I was like
I'm gonna sleep early which was like four in the morning but
that is a lot better than eight in the morning guys that's
that's called improvement one one step at a time that's
called improvement guys from eight to four i cut those four
hours down
but i guess like me me and my body and my mind was not on
the same page because I was so tired from waking, when I set
my alarm at 11.30.
And then even Dad was like, Dad now wakes up via my alarm.
So, like, he knows when he's like, it's feeding time for my
alarm.
Now he doesn't use his biological clock anymore.
Because I think he realized with the new bed, it's useless.
Like, with the new bed, I was like, you can't get me out of
this bed, Dad.
You can't.
Like, your parks do nothing to me anymore.
You wake up when I wake up.
Anyway, so, yeah, because like the moment the alarm rings,
he's like, and then he realized it doesn't work anymore.
He's like, he starts whimpering.
And then he's like, he's trying to like get my attention by
gripping on the edge of the bed.
You know, like, you know, like just standing, trying to like
poke his head up at the edge of the bed, like the end of the
bed.
But the thing is, since the bed is now king-sized, I don't
really see.
him anymore when he does that
when he does that because in the past he would like try to
get the edge of the bed and try to like paw at me but he
can't do that anymore because the bed is so big that he
can't reach me anymore so then he realized that so now he
starts whimpering be like look at me I'm so sad oh I'm so
hungry and sad And I'm just like I was like You can't bait
me You can't fucking guilt trip me I know your games I
fucking know your games
Mother please Please Feed me I'm so hungry And I'm just like
Oh and then I don't You can't hear him But he's starting
park in the moment i said that oh he's like don't tell him
what i do like he's like what did you say i heard you talk
and i don't know if you hear him i don't know if you'll sit
i open the door i don't know if you'll hear him don't expose
me there you see i hope i start talking shit anyway so i
woke at 11 30 i was like i can't i can't i think i woke up
in the middle of my REM cycle or some I need like, I need
like 30 more minutes and I woke up 12 and I texted my
manager and I was like, please push my stream back up 30
minutes.
I can't.
You're embarrassing me, mom.
So you were away.
Yeah, there you are.
I closed the door back up, but you could hear him like, see,
the moment I start talking shit, he starts fucking barking
back.
Anyway, so that's why I've pushed 30 minutes of I was just
my body's just just not ready for today It was you know, the
sleep schedule is not really a schedule at the moment.
I'm trying to slowly fix that
Anyway, today we are going to be playing 007 first light
apparently I talked about this before yesterday, but
I mean, that's like six plus years, right?
Because they have some references and jokes in there that
did not age very well.
And cameos that didn't age very well.
Because, you know, it was supposed to be released a lot
earlier.
But apparently the reviews from audiences and other than
that, that's apparently the one criticism that people had
was just that there's some things that didn't age very well.
because they made this game, you tell they made this game a
while back.
And the thing is, is that, but the thing is, is that critics
and audiences have reviewed this game very, very well.
And so I'm very excited to try this game out.
Apparently it's made by same devs.
Some of this dev team is from the Hitman series, but it's
not necessarily Hitman.
It's his own game.
It doesn't, it's not really like, just hitman but with james
bond skin over it it's apparently its own game it has it
does feel it has some hitman-esque like things in there but
um it's not hitman but a lot of people are saying that it's
very fun like people on steam are saying it's really fun
people uh like on like you know not it's not a mixtape
situation where it's an industry plan or anything and that
seems very exciting.
My regarding my James Bond knowledge.
I've only watched two James Bond movies in my life.
I mean I watched a lot of spy movies but it doesn't
necessarily mean they're James Bond movies.
But I, you know, I do know like some basic things about
James Bond.
I did read some fan fictions back in the day.
Back in the day, you know, I read some fan fictions.
here and there related to the James Bond fandom so it's like
I practically know a lot about James Bond I of course what
parent document that's a secret because you got that's a
little secret I guess you'll never know that just back in
the day before I've reformed you know before okay I told you
guys this before but sometimes um i read fan fictions of
pairings or of like fandoms that i don't even read the
source material of so i just like the characters and i was
like oh the characters are very interesting oh they look
pretty cute together they look really hot together let me
just let me start reading some fan fiction and then like i
gather the knowledge of whatever the The manga, the book is,
based off of the fan fictions I read.
So I've had that, I've done that for, um, I've done that for
One Piece.
But it's like just the general knowledge of like what the
characters are like, the personalities, like just the
general gist of the story just from reading fan fiction.
Like I don't even like get into the source material.
I was just like, these characters, these two characters, I
get it.
it.
I'm just like, huh, these two characters, I get it.
There's just something about those two.
I need to know more.
I need... So I've done that before for several facts.
James Vaughn was one of them.
Same with Doctor Who.
James Vaughn, the Doctor Who.
Doctor Who.
Okay, One Piece.
What else?
What else have I done this for?
Oh, Arcane.
Because of those two characters.
Because I was like, I saw those two.
By the way, I'm still reformed.
I saw those two.
And I was like, I get it.
I get it.
I got it.
Not Doctor Who.
So I was like, I get it.
anyway i'm reformed now but i know it i'm reformed now but
i've done that before um similar to james bond i did read a
bit of the wiki though and but yeah so the only the james
bond films uh i've uh i've watched was what's his name the
daniel craig ones um so that's like my general knowledge of
james bond like you know james bond Q all of that shaken not
stirred and all the little references that people make about
James Bond and everything um so that's that's where I'm at
regarding like what do you know about James oh yeah you're
such a James Bond fan we've named three movies and I was
like I'll I can name two and I can name some fan fictions I
read I can name you too it's like casino royale and the
other one
um why doky why do you remember casino royale so vividly
because like half the movie he was literally just gambling i
was with my i remember i was watching this movie with my
parents and all i could remember was not even half like i
think like 70 to 80 percent of that movie he was literally
just in the casino and doing doing the fucking poker i guess
he was playing poker That's all I can remember.
Oh, and then the homo were erotic tensions between him and
the other guy.
That was not the pairing, by the way.
That was not the pairing that I read above.
But I remember that too.
Wait.
Yeah.
Do you know what?
If you watch the movie, you'll know exactly what I'm talking
about.
If you watch the movie, you'll know exactly what scene I was
talking about when I say that.
Because there is one scene where it gets pretty homo erotic.
And when I say pretty, and that's coming from me too.
That's coming from me.
I was like, damn, that's pretty, that's pretty gay.
Wow, that's maybe a really gay.
Are you watching?
Are we watching the same movie?
No, when you see the scene, you would know that part.
You see that particular scene.
Anyway, so other than that, another thing I'm like, oh, man,
is that there's so many good games coming out right now.
now it's just there's just so many i mean to be fair yes the
torture scene came right after but before that torture scene
before the torture scene it gets pretty gay
anyway so so many good games are coming out in 2026 like
right now just now um mean of the holloway for those who
don't know is the game recently developed uh just released
by the people who made hollow not hollow night shovel night
um and and uh apparently at the moment is rated number one
in metacritic so uh out of all like it's like the best game
so far for 2026 um uh with all the reviews coming in it's
like 10 out 10 9 out 10.
yeah it's the mouse game um and it it seems i don't know
people are seeing it's really really good and i'm like oh
there's so many good games coming out like i have so many
games i need to finish too like i still have to finish
armacore so i've finished Batman not to finish James Bond so
like by the time I finish all of them it'd be like one to
two months and I could play Mina the Holloway I'm just like
ah I wish I had more time to play all of these games and
then I will be gone next week so then it's like I need
another week to finish all of these games like suffering I
don't know it's just There's so many good games coming.
I'm really looking forward to trying out Mina the Hollower I
heard is a Legend of Zelda S-type game And the thing is I
didn't grow up with Legend of Zelda because I didn't grow up
with Nintendo games So I've never really played I think I
told you guys I've never really played a Legend of Zelda
game before The only Legend of Zelda game I played was the
one with a train because it was on a 3DS and I and I It
literally filtered me I don't know I remember I was just I
just did not enjoy it Um, I don't remember what it's called.
I remember she had a train.
It was my first Zelda game ever and then um and I I stopped
after two hours because I was just it was just not fun For
me for me it was just not that fun like I just didn't get it
I was just like you know what?
Let me try out a Zelda franchise.
Maybe I'll try a Zelda game one day on stream but for now I
just have never really played a Legend of Zelda game before
so I really am looking forward to meeting at all or going in
that's blind and if someone will know the knowledge about
Legend of Zelda but with all the reviews coming in people
seem to really enjoy it so I look forward to trying that out
in the future like maybe in two months or something because
I have so many games to finish um so Sharky thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you hey Tokyo's my birthday
today can you get a happy birthday oh Of course you can!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear stuffed sharky!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Woo!
Alright.
Oh yeah, before we begin the game, I forgot to let you guys
know.
I was waiting until like, just to make sure that the song
stays on streaming services but girlfriend is back on
streaming services so um i was just waiting to see if i get
dmca'd again by myself so it is back you want to stream
girlfriend the cover please feel free to stream it on all
spotify youtube apple amazon and the rest because it's on
all of them girlfriend is back on streaming services um and
it should be back for real it's it's stayed alive for like
more than a week now so i feel comfortable i feel
comfortable like listing it now like talking about it
because i i was just like oh man what if oh man it'd be
pretty awkward but i was like it's out now and then it got
taken down again so i had to wait for it until everything is
okay uh carl thank you super chat thank you thank you who
the fucking don't get licensed to kill i did i licensed
myself all right let's see if there's anything else i want
to talk about before we begin
um just looking through my list of everything all right i
think we should i think we're good to go all right let's go
Let's play 007, first light.
I don't know if I should play with controller or not.
Because it's like a shooter.
So I was just like, do I need to shoot my gun with my mouse?
Or shoot my gun with my controller?
Oh, let's check this out.
I'm really excited.
Honestly.
I'm really looking forward to it.
Oh, what about the last guest?
So we're going to wait until streaming services, the
streaming tickets has been fully confirmed before we
announced the last guest.
So I just wanted to let you guys know that I want to be sure
that streaming tickets are fully confirmed because we're
also trying to do a...
uh we're also trying to see if we can stream the like one to
two songs of the concert for free because that's something i
requested as well like a little sneak preview of the concert
um and we want to confirm that if we can do that first
before because like this is something i don't can't say like
oh it's going to happen i just so just something that we're
trying to see if we can make it happen like all the other
concerts out there where whoa it's loading shaders right now
that's why i'm lagging it's loading shaders right now as
always um yeah and so um we're just that's why like we
haven't announced we haven't announced the oh wait is your
oh it's because sorry it's because the game the shaders
broke the stream
i'm getting chat like are we back are we back okay so the
shaders broke the stream i don't even know what you guys
heard or what you guys did in here they got it oh no they
fucking got it sorry shaders almost done it's almost done
guys 85 I don't even know I don't even know when it when I'm
back I'm just waiting are we back my chat is not not
catching up yet you guys listening to the past I heard about
okay oh she okay there we go I'm All right, we're back.
Okay, yeah, I'm here to refresh my chat because my chat is
also delayed, too.
All right, we're back.
All right, what was the last thing you heard from me?
I don't know.
What was the last thing you heard, guys?
So, sound, y'all, get ready.
It's time for your favorite time of the day.
Oh, okay, so...
Oh, yeah, so we're waiting for streaming tickets to be fully
confirmed.
That's something I asked if possible because there's other
companies, other places I've done this where during the
concert, I want to do like a little preview of the concert.
So it's like one to two songs for free.
And then we, you know, and then it's like, boom, then you
want to watch the rest of the concert.
You can feel free to get the streaming tickets and
everything.
So I'm trying to see if we could do that and see if we could
get that confirmed before we announce the last guest.
you're going to have that but you know oh we're so we're
just trying to see you know if it happens it happens if it
doesn't happen we still have streaming tickets so um i do
because you know i want you know not all people can afford
streaming tickets not a lot of people can um can afford to
travel or anything and i still want to do like you know have
like something small that's like you know that's still a
small portion of it just for free for you guys um that's
what i want to try and do make it as accessible as can for
everybody, for all the fans, for all the fans, not just
dragoons, but you know, there's people who are, you know,
the dooboos and sorry, the dooboos, the ibos, you know, I
want to make sure, you know, you guys also have an
opportunity to catch a little bit of the, of the concert and
stuff, so, um, so yeah, so that's why the last guest has not
been confirmed yet.
When we confirm streaming tickets and all of that, then we
can announce the last guest.
The new birds.
Anyway, all right.
Let's see.
Continue.
I just watched the casino royale scene, and it's definitely
buried those guys who put yes, yes.
See, I told you.
I told you.
It's pretty gay.
I'm waiting for thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you I told you guys it's a little gay in that particular
scene it's not me it's not just me you guys seen the scene
you'll know also I'm waiting for my family obviously I
haven't eaten lunch yet like I woke up and went straight to
it um yeah I got all the rewards let's go all right let's
figure out the controls before we go straight into it like i
said i don't know i should use i don't know i should use uh
screen shake okay we'll do 50 like i said i'm not i've never
been a huge fan of screen uh it depends on like it depends
on like what game it is if it was like battlefield i fucking
the screen shake in battlefield is just too much because
you're always shooting your gun so it's like it's like
always a mini earthquake whenever i play that So, I'm just
going to put that in.
It really depends on what type of game it is.
I'm shooting a lot.
I'm just going to put that down.
All right, let's see.
Dexter.
Oh, my God.
Everything is like, oh, my God.
I mean, if it can run that, let's try it.
Let's fucking fuck it.
Let's try it.
Full screen blur effects.
Okay.
Film grade wobble distortion Let's try Let's gamble we're
all in Speaking of casino royale Let's give that a shot So
we're going to have a little mini We're going to have a food
break in During the stream Because I want to eat Alright
Stress test is coming now Alright Enter the number Okay Bond
needs to be more strategic with his health, resources, and
ability while enemies are much more resilient and harder to
counter experience for the battle hardened.
A battle balanced experience which bond enemies are tuned to
give a fairer challenge.
Um, that's too intended, guys.
Like, I don't know how much stuff, like, it really depends
because I don't care, I don't know how much stealth is
involved in the James, in a spy game.
You know, since it is a spy game, you would assume there's a
lot of stealth involved with it because you're a spy.
And I don't think I want to... I don't think I want to do...
I don't think I want extra hard when it's related to
stealth.
Alright.
Guys, I think we... I think the gamma didn't pay off.
Maybe the graphics were too ultra.
The last time you see ultra graphics.
Yeah, it's classified information that only me and a
thousand plus of my friends can do.
Oh, shit.
No, that'll be five.
James Bond is on that play.
It'll be okay.
They definitely shaken, not stirred the play.
Wouldn't be funny if they just killed off James Bond here.
I'm like, thanks for paying 70 plus dollars.
I hope you enjoyed your James Bond experience.
Is that me?
Oh my god, he's such a little baby.
Oh my god.
He hasn't even, like, hooked up with 80 different women yet.
Oh, are we going to get a James Bond sign?
Are we going to get the classic thriller sign?
Oh.
Oh my god.
Isn't he so cute when he drowns?
Wait, can I actually get him to drown here if I don't do
anything?
I mean, this is a good time to read the super chat.
Oh, wait, all right.
There we go.
Let me adjust the graphics.
Hey, Toki.
First time catching a stream live.
Looking forward to seeing you play live.
Let's go.
Double Toki.
Thank you, and super chat.
Thank you.
Hope you enjoyed the stream.
W.
Thank you.
All right, let's let's adjust this real quick.
We'll put it at a high and then see if...
Oh, I hate this.
I'm sorry.
I'm already getting filtered with...
I'm sort of getting filtered already by how these settings
are done.
These are not optimal for... I'm not a fan.
Why do I have to like... Please just have it all extended.
I don't need you to fucking collapse it.
All right.
I'm not a fan of that.
Is there active audio profile?
Oh, that's cool.
Mutant when minimized.
No, we'll just put that here.
I just don't like it when they collapse it together.
You know what I'm saying?
But I just don't like that.
It just feels very...
Oh, I have to mind to play Medium.
Alright, I know it was very pretty, guys.
But...
I know, yes, it was so pretty.
But at least we got her.
At least we were able to see how pretty it was for two
minutes.
Yeah, I hate the nesting stuff.
It's, I hate it.
It's just unnecessary.
Do I need to change the texture filter too?
Do I need to change, do I have to change that too?
Does that also do anything or does it not?
I don't know if the tri-linear does anything.
Because we got to make sure I stop lagging.
All right.
Resolution scaling off.
Do we have to turn this down at all?
Dragons?
I just need to know.
But I want to see each strand of James Bond.
We're not seeing in our hearts, guys.
is off it should always be off um i
don't know i don't know if i should turn this down at all
i'm just gonna say no oh chromatic it was this whatever full
screen what the fuck is chromatic aberration good luck being
bond who has a license to kill and takes in the living
daylights video man the us super chat thank you thank you I
don't really, I don't even know.
I don't even know, like, wait, I already lost my train of
thought.
Never mind.
Oh, yeah, I don't like the menu design at all.
I'm not a fan of the menu design.
It's pretty ass.
I do not like how they did the settings.
Oh, mimicking a old lens.
Okay, let's see.
looks great.
Oh, I'm still lagging though.
Maybe it looks a little too great.
Can I actually die in the cutscene?
Alright.
I'm just stress testing him.
I'm stress testing James Bond right now.
No, he seems pretty much alive.
Alright.
Here we go again.
Oh!
Yeah, you've been in the water.
for, like, at least five minutes now.
Those are some strong-ass lungs.
All right, sound guys.
Let me know.
I mean, it's still beautiful, even if we're all menia.
All right, maybe not as beautiful.
We actually, you know, I'm curious.
What does it look like in ultra high?
Now I'm curious, guys.
What does it look like?
Let's check this out.
Let's see the comparison now that we're out of the water.
Because, you know, when we're in the water, we're in the
water.
You can't really do much about water textures.
So, it feels very similar.
You're not going to lie.
It doesn't change much for me.
Yeah.
Not too much of a huge difference.
Not going to lie.
Unless, like, maybe it's just me trying to cope.
Or I could be coping.
I could be coping.
It's kind of the same.
Or I'm coping.
It's one or the other.
Yeah.
All right, medium, medium, medium.
Medium, medium, medium, medium, medium, medium.
All right.
is that is that really what ultra graphics is it's just a
little shinier just a little bit shinier do i turn v-sync
off does that help i don't remember i always forget about
v-sync if it's like v-sync off helps with
yeah oh shit it's all right
apparently this game is pretty optimized for like modern
games which is not saying much but you know it's it's nice
that they try that they still you know care it's
at home that's me i'm james bond hello guys i'm gonna be a
big boy soon
i don't think i've ever played a james bond game i never
played golden eye or any of those games this is my first
time playing an actual james bond game He seems very much
alive.
Hello, little guy.
Oh!
Surely he's part of the same team, right?
Are they speaking?
They're clearly speaking English.
Right?
Hello, fellow soldiers in the same, on the same side of the
war.
How do you do?
Funny, are they trying to...
around all right get dodged
all right off we go yeah it's just guys it's just they're
speaking English with a very heavy accent also I do not know
if sound guy is alive I haven't heard anything in chat oh
I'm a little just a little little concern.
Just a little bit.
They got him.
Sound guy was on the helicopter.
Just means it sounds.
Okay, we're just gonna go by heart.
Okay, I feel like it might be a little too loud, but that's
just the feeling.
But we'll turn the music down and the effects down just so
the voice Can be at 20.
I don't know if sound guy is...
Do we have any of the mods alive?
What am I supposed to do here?
Oh, here.
I bring down overall for now, alright?
Okay, crouching in tall grass.
That didn't mash that.
See?
They're clearly speaking English.
very intense game of hide-and-seek.
Sorry to turn around.
Should be good.
Oh, shit!
Bon was killed.
Would you like to change difficulty?
I thought I was okay!
I was like, time to stand up!
Enough stealth.
I'm done with stealth.
See, this is why we play on the hardest difficulty this is
that's the end of the bot series he's dead now
all right well now that i know i should not stand up
all right all right now that i know that i need to stand
down
oh shit okay okay I I can be patient guys I can be a really
good spy try to play it like Metal Gear someone did not
watch my Metal Gear series so someone it definitely did not
watch my Metal Gear series if you're suggesting me to play
it like Metal Gear.
Gotta get there eventually.
Alright, I'm very patient.
I can be a very patient person.
Oh, hey, there's more grass over there.
Okay, guys, I just noticed that there was another patch of
grass.
I'm sorry, I'm not used to touching grass, guys.
I'm not used to touching grass.
I didn't realize there was a second patch of grass.
With
choppers down, hostiles are organized and heavily armed.
Well, there's, like, at least three.
I think.
Right?
We're taking control of this mission effective in me.
Oh, my God.
That's my trial.
Because we need your help.
What's your name, soldier?
Bond.
Oh.
You're not SAS.
Air crewmen?
In training.
We'll have to make do.
James Bond.
No,
but there's some light coming from the other side of the
mountain.
That's it.
Get there.
All right, we just gotta get there.
Okay.
Yeah, don't they need to be crushed anymore.
I should be good to go now.
See, I told you they were speaking English.
They're playing hide-and-seek.
And I'm winning.
I'm winning the hide-and-seek game.
We're on the same side of the war.
Look at that.
We're on the same team.
there's just some space to dismount all right are you sure
you're up for this adrenaline can mask even significant
damage better keep those levels up then he's a baby i think
maybe it's like his first mission unless we're gonna get
like a little montage of him becoming a spy i think we're
gonna get him i think this is like he's gonna wake up and
was all a dream he's dreaming about like his very first
mission and stuff and then his the hot babe next he was like
nothing she's like oh let's go again capable and well
organized expeditary firearms are unfamiliar i guess special
issue that's good keep your eyes peeled all right why is my
six getting involved here the retrieval camp has been
compromised how and by whom is what i need your help
figuring out yeah but why am i sick it's just some old scars
okay and then the baby retrieval mission then also
classified oh how can i help and baby was like you want to
take a shower with me and it bonds like later sugar yes mom
the james bond girls the bond girls that's what they're
called right let's max out the dial oh the Dialogue.
Oh, hey, sound guy.
The dialogue is maxed out.
They're called Bond Girls, right?
Alright.
Dialogue has been maxed out.
Sound guy.
Have you located the camp?
Not yet.
I hope I'll see it when I clear the top.
Alright, yeah.
And then he's like, not now, babe.
And then the girl goes, the Bond girl goes to take a shower.
And then he used a hotel room and then and then and then and
then she cries You tell when he's a baby before you was
James Bond because he doesn't have the the posh accent yet
You dodging the question and you're hypothermic get to the
camp and find some warm clothes.
I need you operational Farcore
Am I doing this the hard way?
Or like the actual way?
Because there's like the up and the down.
I'm going to go the up.
I'm going to take the high ground.
I like how they gave us two ways to do this.
It's like you want parkour or you want to be a pussy?
And I'm like parkour!
Yeah, you want to be James Bond or Q right now?
Yeah, it's like hardcore.
Why won't they let me hang?
There you go.
Yeah, because like, I don't think I have.
Oh, never mind.
I'm okay.
I found the camps, ma'am.
I did it.
I found the camp.
I see some perimeter markers.
Good.
You're close to the camp.
It's like literally right there.
fingers and toes water certainly doesn't help you're in
water again better than getting spotted
it's nice that they all speak English too they're inclusive
this one's armed they are all armed thank you MI6 saves us
the trouble MI6 explosives You're the ones running your
retrieval mission.
Oh, convenient.
I know, right?
It's a set of grid of high explosives covering the whole
area.
It's a post-mission cleanup measure.
Thermochemical sterilization.
I didn't want you to get worried.
No.
Chemical sterilization.
What's the worry about?
Thermo.
And it's quite safe.
What's not, however, is you still out in the cold.
Yes.
I know.
All right.
Ooh.
I can't wait to figure out all these controls later.
All these stuff controls later.
All right.
There's a window here I can get through.
All right, gonna stay warmed up.
That'll do.
Good news.
Parker.
On top of the wet clothes?
Oh.
just oh shit i know their language oh now they speak their
language you speak serbian montenegro picked up a few
phrases while mountain climbing there a few phrases that
man's giving you a having a conversation already on it i
found a receipt November 17th paid in cash interesting yeah
now they don't speak English
yeah this was a conversation I don't think you have these
conversations during mountain climbing a briefcase it's full
of ashes one of ours self-ignites if I were wrong that's a
spy thing remember when I went to the spy museum and I
showed you I showed you guys the part where they put in the
rat.
It's like, oh my god, there was a bomb in that rat.
Yeah, there's a spa museum in New York City.
Pretty cool.
It's pretty neat.
Sorry,
my food was here.
So I had to make sure I don't talk when I pick up the...
When I answer the intercom.
Because then they'll be like, what the...
Yeah.
Someone's lying here.
He's been shot.
Vitals.
I think he's alive.
He looks alive.
Just a little bit of blood loss.
He's dead.
Oh.
Foster.
One of yours.
Senior engineer.
Keep going.
I guess he wasn't.
It's hard to tell.
it's a bit hard to tell you know looks like he was sleeping
oh nice a gun guns what kind it's a txk biome cereal's gone
discontinued also it's biometrically locked oh i can't use
it it's biometrically locked that's for one gun seems very
inconvenient too.
I know I could just open the door.
I could have washed my face a little bit.
Not gonna lie.
I guess now that I'm wearing the mask should be fine.
Yeah, sound guy max the volume.
If I stand next to you, hello.
what's wrong with you push dano you'll never know i'm a spy
hey
guys so that's new recruit so rude i just wanted to know if
he'll shoot me i'm just stress testing it out I'm a police
shooter.
I just wanted to know I'm stress testing.
Red and white checkers.
In this context, could reference Croatia?
The fact that he didn't shoot me, it means that some of
these recruits here are as incompetent as me.
That's just a site explosives protocol from the MI6
handbook.
Rocket launcher.
Serial 394 KLB 211.
is part of a u.s shipment stolen in algea is nine years ago
we never punished keep digging we're not done yeah i'm just
gathering intel guys now i know their recruits are just as
stupid as me
see i barely crushed that thing see i'm not i'm not as bad
hey what's wrong with you da da no Nothing?
Are you stupid?
But yeah, no.
Just wanted to know.
All right, we got acorns.
All right.
Where's Jovan when you need him?
Wasn't up for it this time.
Those nine mill lost on the German job.
My uncle got me this job.
So they can't fire me.
It's just that Byron understands so well he hears it as it
as if it was English.
I like that in his mind.
He gives them an accent.
He gives them a Serbian accent.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to mention a messy German job.
Nine million lost.
Hang on.
I know exactly who we're up against.
A Balkan gang of thieves known as Arrowhead.
Notorious for never leaving any witnesses.
Listen.
I'm going to ask you to enter the big central town.
But what you learn in there can never be mentioned to
anyone.
Oh, there's rice here.
I need to hear you say that you accept and acknowledge its
ramifications.
That's accepting Serbian.
What are you going to do, huh?
What are you going to do if I piss you off, huh?
My uncle works for the Serbian government.
That's thinking right.
Oh, you're going to do it.
Pussy that's the king right That's right.
I have immunity Oh,
you don't care
That's on you.
Yeah, see that's your fault To keep police Yeah, do this way
Who the fuck is this new guy?
I heard this guy.
Alright.
Gotta go in there.
Oh, that man's smoking.
What the fuck?
Where did that guy come from?
Hey.
Hey!
No smoking!
That's fucking right.
No smoking around the tent.
You know who I am?
Any bombs I should know of?
None you should know of.
It was shame he dropped his cigarette.
Oops, I'm so clumsy.
Oh.
Sorry, Gapser.
I can't.
You're still on a need-to-know basis.
Figures.
Mission protocol gray envelope forbids I think making a good
first impression.
I'll not discuss any specifics.
I don't think they know I'm a spy, guys.
I think I'm blending right in.
Yeah, exactly.
next to the oxygen tank.
I had to protect the tent.
Oh, I'm losing connection.
What's that noise?
Distortion.
Oscillating.
Oh, not feeling so good.
Alright.
That goes through here.
Sound good.
Haven't heard from you in a while.
Are you alive?
You just said turn turn.
Turn up the dialogue and then you disappeared.
Did they get him?
Oh, BC.
And that is right.
It's gone.
They got him.
Wait,
did they actually?
They just said turn or bring up the overall.
Okay, I see it now.
the overall slightly and turn down okay i see it i like how
the menu is like higher is like basically higher graphics
than everything here all right bring up overall
all right overall and then turn down sound effects and music
all right Let me know if it's better.
I brought it up.
Sorry, I was too busy pushing the Serbians into a corner.
Alright, running shouldn't be that suspicious.
Oh.
Just keep looking.
Is there a concussion?
I did land on the sand.
Oh, there's nothing here.
It should be okay.
I'm James Bond.
worst things are gonna happen to me sorry our sound guy
wasn't speaking in serbian so i couldn't tell are you sure
it's completely sealed i got too engrossed in there i got
too immersed as a spy i'm wearing hazmat suits should i
worry give me a sec that was method acting let's get the
hell out of here we get on this happen in three weeks strike
gold in brazil works for me preparing the final cleanup now
ever been to brazil first time welcome to brazil did you
mention the sound distortion before yeah i need you to do
exactly as i say do you see the red door head for it yeah
that's red right you've been exposed to an oh a nerve agent
oh so it wasn't a concussion we're going to brazil see even
in serbia people wants to go to brazil
You should be fine.
I'm not wearing a hazmat suit, right?
Oh, the distortion.
Is that green?
All right, there you go.
That has to be green.
That's...
It says medical.
All right.
Okay, there's another green box.
I see it.
It has to be this.
It's a distortion.
I'm just getting immersed into the nerve agent.
The orange one.
Do not use the other one.
What's orange?
Which one's orange?
I'm injecting both.
Don't worry, it's a 50-50.
It counteracts each other.
I can't see shit.
What?
you okay that might be pushing it what next what how where
did this guy come from you've done great we'll have an
extraction team pick you up in about an hour she said don't
inject both he's like I'm gonna inject I'm gonna inject both
and they're about to leave yes and we'll let them thanks to
you we've been able to deduce exactly who the buyer is where
they'll be meeting and at what time will intercept in a
controlled environment with no risk to the asset you just
get out of the camp oh he also got hit with the nerve gas
but it's a little inconvenient to only have one antidote for
something they're working on i don't fancy his chances i'll
follow see what i can do it doesn't seem very convenient
i'll spot you and kill you remember who you're up against
I gotta follow the guards.
It's parkour time.
I'm taking this one to the others.
G9 or V4.
They're all inside the classroom.
What's the point then?
They're all going to die anyway.
I guess it is sort of cheaper to hire.
They just shot him.
No witnesses.
Oh.
Alright.
I guess we didn't save him.
Our first failed mission.
still alive but the hostiles plan to blow up the place you
need to get out of the blast zone oh i need to save those
people that is not your call stand down that's an order
listen carefully you have less than one percent chance of
success that's that's higher than gotcha rates okay all
right sounds good that's good i'll take those odds that
means i can pull
true if I let it ride I got standing environment so
you have to go up B4 or is the containers before and G9 oh
there's the containers G9 wait
can I even That's where I'll find the captives.
Do I just go in?
I'm just trying to decide how do I reach the perimeters.
Do I have...
I'm just like wondering, is it safe?
Is there anybody?
There's nobody there, right?
There's no one grinding the door, so it should be safe.
Alright, let's test it.
Only one way to find out.
Oh
You're so safe.
I told you only one way to find out Look at this guy was
writing hope to his wife Miss you tell Thomas and Martha
that the huh Let's see
Oh I can do a cover takedown get over here.
That's right What's this?
Oh, it's biometrically locked.
I should be able to open this door now.
Hello?
Any prisoners?
Alright.
Of course I didn't hear anything.
Look at those masks and helmets.
I know, we should be okay now.
Let's collect this.
Oh, my food's here.
Let me grab my food real quick.
Actually, nobody's going to come in, right?
I'll grab my food.
Oh, got the key.
Give me a sec.
I'll get my food.
All right.
All right, no.
All right, let's free it.
Sorry, prisoners.
Sorry.
James Bond had to do a little food break.
There you are.
Nick, uh, wait.
Papa, thank you, a super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Free us.
Hey, listen.
We've done a bunch of time, and we need to get you out of
here.
What's the plan?
Can't we just sit tight and wait for the others to deal with
the hostiles?
I'm all you've got.
Just one guy.
That's me.
All right, that's not.
Hey, hey, look.
I freed you.
There's others.
Okay.
this business and she groups like you know a thank you would
be nice okay you need to stay put while i free them and run
east on my signal what kind of signal you'll know when you
see it that's crazy i can't believe they were cooked while
i'm in front of me like bro what thanks for the confidence
could
be like thank you sir for saving my life not like we're
we're gonna die
I'm believe it now James need to find those captains so
underappreciated hey one airman that fucking untied them
okay he
looked at me and said GG's all right container B4 where are
What is on the other side?
Just what I need.
What do you say?
Besides, he was a sucker for all things gentlemen.
Do you think they saw me?
Do you must?
Okay.
I'm fine.
Because I think they saw me.
I think...
I think they saw me.
saw me you think the captains are right maybe they were
right to say gg god speed okay
the captains are gunshots and then they're like oh we're
They might
have been right.
All right, container B4.
Where are you?
Heavy duty.
Just what I need.
Too much company for my liking.
Got to find a way around.
Besides, he was a sucker for all things general.
I don't think he'd care.
Okay.
All right, this time.
See you guys?
There will be barriers.
Do you mind?
Anything!
Just stop it!
How?
I don't know how to drive this thing!
Shit!
Help me get our stuff out of the way!
Good girl.
Alright.
I should keep them busy.
Should be able to use that crevasse to avoid being spotted.
Did I use that crevasse?
Nice.
You got some luck to be?
I had enough sunshine on the place where I tried to...
Huh.
He's just stopped talking.
I wonder what happened to him.
I guess that's what happened to him.
Is there anything in here?
Why would it make me go through this corridor?
Must have been the wind.
Fuck is B.
Oh, B2.
I see him.
Okay, but I could go to F8.
But what if I go to F8, though?
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
I don't think there was loot.
Iceland postcard.
Unfinished postcard by one of the researchers.
Gau Dagen from Iceland.
I'm telling you, bro.
You need to get up here.
You'll absolutely love it.
it places out of the world even the fermented shark isn't as
bad as it sounds to say on the back it's worse and g spot
has been everywhere
is this not b2 oh b4 i'm sorry i can't count
oh you see
Okay, I definitely wish I was not supposed to be there.
Okay, there's B4.
All right, guys.
I see it.
Hey, how am I...
Do I...
Hmm.
Seems to be a lot of people around us.
Can I hang from here?
Oh, there we go.
I knew it.
I was like, why would there be tall grass just leading me to
the edge of the cliff?
Yeah.
Seems a little too suspicious.
This B4 is here.
I feel like I should be on the edge here still.
Yeah.
Just hang around.
Let me cook, guys.
See?
I don't know.
You think my little fingers are spiders?
Exactly.
I don't know what this problem is.
We got what we can.
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
There's a little secret tunnel.
How do I get up there?
Anybody around me?
Okay, there's a lot of people here.
Pass me this way, because there's tall grass here.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck do I get in?
How do I get in?
There was a window?
The yellow box.
Oh, there was a window.
There was a window.
We found it ourselves.
you could have saved them if you had spoken up why so quiet
you don't want to shout or cry your friends die protecting
nothing what a waste tell me what do they pay you at MI6 you
die to keep secrets or protect equipment or high detonator
are you stupid I take risks but I and rich of course I'm
very good so the risk maybe not so big pay still very good
some special cars parties I'm smarter I invest let him
finish I'm just teasing you you're dead no matter what you
know it I know it we leave no trace the bus is strict that
way
there we go see I'm so polite I let him finish thank god
you're finally here thank god you finally did something I
want to know more about his life before I kill him what are
you waiting for cut the tie oh wow can you say please I'm
gonna eat my food then why don't you eat yeah why don't I
hey you know the magic word god these people are all so rude
they're all so rude can't even say please or thank you what
are you waiting for cut the tie i'm eating why don't you
untie us it's a good time for a food break come on untie us
bob just stared so ungrateful what's the magic word why
don't you untie us I mean I was so nice I let that guy
finish his monologue where he was like you're dead we know
it you know it I was like oh you're talking about yourself
right I'm just here to replace the guard yeah why don't you
untie us yeah why don't I I don't know say the magic word
come on untie us what are you waiting for cut the tie what
am I waiting for Why don't you untie us?
Come on, untie us.
What are you waiting for?
Cut the tie.
Why don't you untie us?
I don't say to wait for this magic word!
What are you waiting for?
Cut the tie.
What am I waiting for?
Oh, yeah.
Why don't you untie us?
Come on, untie us.
Listen, I already freed your friends.
We don't have much time.
The hostiles are planning to blow up the camp.
Oh, God.
Yeah, now we don't have much time.
Still, these guys mean business.
We need to go.
Wait for my signal.
What's the signal?
Any ideas?
If you topple the central vast, we'll all hear it.
It's barely standing in this storm.
I wonder where it all the time went.
Here, the detonator.
You better take it.
Yeah.
There's just no time.
Where did all the time go?
Thank you.
See?
Oh, now they say good luck.
All right.
Time to bring the house.
Sabotage!
Alright, we gotta escape the cap, but where's the exit?
Oh, this way.
How do I get down?
Alright, we gotta leave.
Easy!
Look at that!
Wait, they saw him!
I'm a hero!
Oh, shit!
Quick time event!
There we go.
Easy.
I'm a hero.
And that's what he did.
He hesitated.
Or are we doing the signal?
Oh, is that my first kill?
There's no way this is my first kill.
Oh, I guess because like I was just an in-training air
crewman.
I've never killed before.
Look at that.
He took Bonn's first time.
We lost his killgenity.
Okay, what's the point of having a giant tanky?
We can't even kill anybody.
Oh, it was when...
When I was...
Wait, I'm not even licensed yet!
You never forget your first time, guys!
Oh my god, I killed without a license!
Without protection!
Everybody okay?
Follow me this way.
There's a way out.
Alright.
It's good that you know we're...
It's literally the James Bond themed!
Oh,
you got a license for that killer?
I've got the detonator!
Hold your fire!
What is this now?
You want to blow us up?
Yeah, thinking about it.
I was like,
A good thing I'm not in the end.
Yeah!
I wrote this game!
Boom!
No hesitation.
I think about the consequences to a keep.
Oh,
it is!
Achieve the spy intruders.
I promise you'll never dream.
I'm surprised too.
See you running towards the sun.
Like a
moon.
We'll try and stop you.
All the fates just watch you.
Dying just to know.
Bum.
Oh
my god, that's one of my bond girls.
Man, thank you, the Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Of course, they have to include the Bond song.
The Bond intro.
It's a classic.
Every Bond movie has that.
And not every Bond game.
Oh.
There's double oh seven.
Where's double D seven?
James Bond.
You sound familiar?
Today's not about me.
It's about you and the incident last month.
Come on.
Your visitors pass, Mr. Bond.
Thanks.
That's me!
You said the thing!
Hunch bot, jeans bot.
Try one more bite.
Bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam.
Where were we?
Gotta say you're healing fast.
Sorry, just trying to get past you.
Sorry.
You're on a visitor's path, so you need to sit with me.
What are you looking at?
Apologies.
and what are you looking at right then it was you anyhow
we're going upstairs yeah you're in the way yeah that's
right that's right yeah why are you standing in front of me
I'm in trouble did I say that I wouldn't have that's
Confidential.
See?
He was in my way!
Is this about me hanging up on you in Iceland?
I have no idea what you're talking about.
Alright, if that's how you want it.
Pleased to meet you, I'm James.
And you are...
Infuriatingly secretive.
What else do I have to do?
Alright, no more.
Let's play the game.
I'll eat this later.
I just have to get a couple of energy in me before we
continue.
I mean, it's her voice.
Money penny?
What's your favorite dessert?
Are there crepes or crepes?
Or tiramisu is always good.
Green tea ice cream, crepes, tiramisu.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
That's rude, you know.
Unintentional.
Just coming through.
Sorry.
I tripped.
So your name is Money Penny.
Oh, it is Money Penny.
Now let's not get carried away, James.
At least tell me who I'm meeting.
You're here to see M.
M.
Right.
M!
You're really enjoying this, aren't you?
And you're not.
How am I going to meet Q?
I might meet Q after.
It's unintentional, guys.
He was just, I was looking at my phone and I said bumped
into him.
Take a seat.
M will be ready shortly.
Oh, look, there's tea and crumpets.
The daily tidings.
You see, I'm going to meet the King of England.
It's so weird that now it's like the King of England, no
longer the Queen.
Code names.
You know, I didn't get much info about today's meeting.
M, is that a codename?
Would be odd for a surname, wouldn't it?
Well, let me guess then.
Master...
Monster?
You're very talkative, aren't you?
Just wanna...
I'm just trying to be polite.
Just wanna get to know you.
This M character is here in prosecution somehow.
She...
He is.
I was like, gee.
Disciplinary board?
She handles some of that, too, yes.
Right.
I do enjoy a quiet office.
Perhaps we can limit the small talk.
I'm sure M will be with you shortly.
Yes, of course.
I don't know what I'm doing here.
Right away.
M will see you now.
I don't know if I haven't gotten enough info.
Take a seat.
Can't believe I can't romance the granny.
Oh my god, she's young.
So, Iceland.
Air crewmen in training.
I'm so used to seeing M as like, Meryl Streep or something.
Well, not Meryl Streep, obviously, but like, but like, you
know, around that age.
And ultimately, Blow up.
She's young.
I said, we were there to retrieve.
I wasn't aware I was under MI6 command, and I just chose not
to take your advice.
Come on.
Yeah, Judy Dench, yeah.
You know?
That means I can romance it.
Yeah, I always feel like M would be like around Judy Dench
age.
Several disciplinary...
Ah, here.
Issues with authority.
case of authority having issues with me look I know where
this is going you can spare me the velvet gloves do you mind
telling me why I'm here hey if she's that young it means I
can romance her she might be a bond girl I would like you to
join his majesty's secret service I want to make you a spy
and what I want you to join my training program though I
have to warn you it's unlikely you'll Oh my god, I got
scouted.
I'm going to get a job.
She gave me a job application.
Normal social life is near impossible.
And if you do get caught, we will deny ever having heard of
you.
How does that sound?
What's the downside?
Money's terrible.
When do I start?
Now, money pennies waiting for you outside.
I'm literally risking my life.
Yeah.
Put him through.
You're dismissed.
Well, I see the fucking spy gadgets.
There's no way.
Well, I already passed the application.
Nice.
Oh my god, you got closer.
Want some back?
I now know what M stands for.
Yeah, he does this for the level of the game.
No, I'm done.
That's right.
I got a job now.
okay i know i was like now stop eating but i couldn't help
it i thought i was gonna have a long cut scene it was gonna
be like my pop or no oh
a little bit of the food got stuck in my mouth but not like
stuck as in like now where's money the texture was scratchy
and it touched the back of my throat.
You know that feeling?
I hate that feeling.
The scratchy texture.
Look at that.
Got a job now.
Yeah.
You're joining?
I am.
Makes the walk down a lot less awkward.
You're in the program too.
Just got assigned.
I'll be the girl in the chair.
Quite excited about it.
I've been reading up on the double-edged.
and I think the program deserves a reboot.
Well, so it's a new thing then.
The chat...
So you have some catching up to do.
What about the Chinese?
And he's off.
I literally heard them say the Chinese and I was like, huh?
I had to chug a little drink of water.
I couldn't bring myself to watch it.
Better get you up to speed.
As I said, basic training and initial elimination rounds
already concluded.
Bum.
All of them have excelled.
Final exams are in six months and you'll have to ace all of
them to qualify for skill duty.
That's assuming that Greenway lets you stay on for that
long.
Greenway?
Training instructor.
Missions above people and orders above principles sort of
guy.
Judging from your profile, I'm sure you're getting it.
along splendidly anyway i'm sending you to the mi6 training
facility in malta where you'll be joining the other recruits
your flight's waiting for you so you better get a move on
break your leg james
i was gonna say it feels very kingsman-esque too yes and
you're late it's literally the kingsman recruitment thing i
love Kingsman.
Oh, I wish they made more sequels.
I love that.
I'm so sad that they ended at two movies.
Oh, man.
They were, and then they killed off all the characters.
Ah.
That was one of my favorite.
Kingsman is one of my favorite movies of all time.
The amount of times I've watched the first movie.
It was so good.
One and two.
In fact, shouldn't be here at all.
Sooner you realize that the better for both of us most
sight-seeing got it the apparently the prequel is not great
I never watched the prequel but already it's not the same I
want egg Z give you a chance and I'll take it yes until you
get bored or the works too hard I read your file to do this
you need skill discipline and above I never watched the
prequel, but I heard it wasn't as good.
It just wasn't as good as the original and the second movie.
I haven't watched it, though.
I miss Harry.
Harry and Dinky Dinky.
Bit of a splurge on the defense budgets.
We live up to or surpass all requirements for an
intelligence service.
why I'm here.
Yeah, relax, Harry and easy charm.
You have a knack for stating the obvious.
I'm just surprised.
I didn't know they trained in Malta.
I expect the list of things you don't know is quite
extensive.
Come on.
This way.
The king, you do tell me this like, no, the Kingsman fandom
said it wasn't as good and I trust my girls.
A hold shift to it, right?
Excuse me.
My fault.
Oh, is that the training?
Meet our new star, Air Crewman Bond.
So capable, he could skip basic training.
He'll now demonstrate his superior close combat skills.
Monroe, will you do the honors?
Love to.
all right show me what you go who is this guy fight back oh
wait he's fighting back oh shit he fought back guys oh my
god i expected to fight back oh shit i just know how to left
click that's all the moves i know apparently Do I not know
anything else?
Fine.
Perhaps some basic training might still be needed.
I just know.
I just know how to left click.
I tasked you with bringing him up to speed.
What's up?
He gets two weeks to pass basics.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, consider it a challenge, Kressida.
You like those.
You know what?
I'll up this one notch.
This was a setup.
two credits from both of you.
Hey, guys.
I hope we'll be great friends.
I do love a challenge.
Respectfully, sir.
Yeah, wasn't I in the fucking army?
I guess they only taught me how to use a gun.
We only know how to fly, guys.
Sorry.
and left click.
Everyone hates me.
I don't know why.
Why does everyone hate me?
Let's try to feel my best.
So yesterday was fun.
Listen.
I don't know who the hell is playing favors for you.
Obviously someone up high, but you won't get any from me.
Better candidates were cut.
And as far as I'm concerned, you should only be here if
you've earned it.
Well, you and Greenway both.
Oh, they're just hazing.
You're right.
It's high school all over.
It's first year university.
What the fuck?
Crescita's our top driver.
She'll take you through the drill.
Learn from the best, as they say.
And you better learn fast.
Care to explain the car?
Oh, 60 B.S.
A classic.
real-life action to you back this is like the Kingsman first
movie go on then get in do a lap around the island get a
feel for her oh shit okay drive it with mouse and keyboard
let's see how this goes I'll come along show you the course
and give you a few pointers all right driving time w-a-d oh
it's not that bad if you want to prove Monroe wrong you need
to up your game slow down for the slow what gas gas gas use
the hand rate for sharp turns not half bad try to stay I'm
drifting but that see I'm such a good drive well oh it's
okay just a little nudge pretty solid for a first run that
was pretty good next time let's see you go far all right
give me a faster car what the fuck oh it's oh it's actually
a training montage oh my god this is my training montage
there you go i i like how the tutorial is a training montage
that's clever that's really clever go i know how to dodge
now guys oh all right all right q bam
that's right right cqc give me a hundred one two
That's so clever.
I like that.
I like that my tutorial is actually a training montage.
Just like the movies.
For the love of God.
If you had enough misery for one night.
We're here.
Speed run.
I thought they would actually make me press it 100 times.
Not gonna lie.
I was ready.
I was ready with my keyboard.
Can't wait to forget all of this next in two weeks.
Oh my god.
In two weeks.
Hit three targets.
Something like that.
Like that?
Where they all line up for me?
Guys.
This might be bad because I realized Oh my god, he got
close.
He got closer.
I realized that the next time I play this is in two weeks So
I absolutely will forget the controls
Okay, but there was a shortcut here.
Oh My god Dad, please I did it.
Okay 99
100 Wait, no!
No!
Oh!
100!
Oh shit, 100!
There we go.
Okay.
My bad.
My bad, James.
Wait.
Okay.
My gun.
hold on you two get in the ring okay let's do this all right
all right get over here fucking right get out of here bam
oh I can grab an enemy I didn't even realize that well I
just started punching I just started Punching.
Doing everything I got.
Look at me go.
Oh.
Oh, shoot the legs.
I wanted to go straight into...
Oh, oh, that's cool.
I like that.
I like that feature.
I can shoot the guns off their hat.
I like that way.
That's clever.
Good talk.
That's a cool...
I like that tech.
I get to shoot the gun out of their hands.
I mean, I could literally just headshot them.
That's cool.
That they implemented that.
You don't see that in a lot of games, too.
That's cool mechanics.
You didn't know what to do.
I didn't want to be rude.
Air crew, you're up.
What?
If you're serious about earning your place, Monroe any
dating horror stories you care to share you look like a man
who's had a few you think this is a joke take it easy mate
okay press F to fake surrender well I thought you knew I
don't have to earn this I can just get by on blind luck
right who needs luck when you've got the old boy network on
your side
oh That's right.
Now the student has become the teacher.
Oh, I don't think he likes that.
And kick him in the nuts!
That's fucking right!
Get out of here!
I'll do it again!
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
That forgot.
It's okay.
I can press Q all day.
What do you mean, Bun?
What did I do?
Me, Bun!
I do want to see what a failed quick time event of that
looks like.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think I already forgot how to counter.
I forgot, guys, which button was to counter key again?
I already forgot.
I can see, okay, I kept pressing, I kept pressing Q.
Wait, it is Q.
How come it didn't parry?
All right, there you go.
Parry, stop blocking.
Okay, sometimes when you parry, it blocks for some reason.
That's why I was so confused.
It wouldn't, it would like block instead of parry.
So I was like, am I pressing the wrong button?
Do it again.
There we go.
Oh, is it because of timing?
Oh!
I didn't realize it was a timing thing.
I just see yellow glow.
Okay, do it again.
That's looking right.
Let me throw you out.
That's right.
All right.
God, I'm so tempted to fail the quick time events.
I really want to know.
I want to know if it's like the heavy rain situation.
Just me and my bro.
Having a good time.
Just can't help yourself, can you?
Yeah, we just sort of damaged thousands of people.
dollars of property so this is on me i decided to take the
sparring outside of the ring things boys being boys don't
take the blame for him monroe honestly sir he's cleared his
close combat requirements i just really want his test damn
what a test if that was out of line i apologize just
slightly i expected better from you And Monroe, if you want
this mess, clean it up.
Enemies to love it.
Yeah, some mice call it that.
You passed basic training.
Congratulations.
That was basic?
However, the least was ever the matter of your performance
review.
Bond is immature and reckless.
guided by his gut feelings and mistaken ideas of loyalty
he's a bad influence on the other yeah this other guy beat
me up I'm loyal to him now greenway recommends that I cut
you from the program he beats the living shit out of me now
we're bros it's been a pleasure mom I want to show you
something come oh
neat trick yes i'd rather enjoy it myself what's down there
you'll see but first let me give you some context i've been
heading mi6 for 14 only 14 months how many terror attacks
have we had on british soil in that period as far as i know
none dead agents blown covers i wouldn't know mom also none
oh the number of prevented or secretly resolved conflicts i
mean that means she's good at her job i feel like 14 months
is not too many months though
They're like, we need more, we need more years to like
actually judge.
He's with me.
There's no need.
It's like only a year.
Never before have we had a success rate like now.
Never before the precision, safety, Intel quality.
What a humble brag.
Such high standards.
Unprecedented.
Just so humble, guys.
Unwilled by anyone else in the Intel community.
So humble.
Oh, and the pay is bad?
This is the reason for our success.
Meet Thayer.
The world's first and only second generation quantum
computer.
I thought those things were theoretical at best.
That's what we want you to think.
Thayer synthesizes millions of data streams to make
statistical deductions on matters of national security the
systems all but wiped the floor with GCHQ so it wasn't even
her it was fucking AI lives thwarted more attacks lost fewer
people that was there in Iceland in case you were wondering
guiding you every step of the way how's there and yet it was
wrong they gave you a less than 1% chance of success you
simply beat the odds that I didn't realize those were actual
odds still you proved an important I thought that was You
see I strongly believe I thought that was the other girl
money beggar Heart and intuition in modern money.
I'm sorry.
I just remember the money part back the double o's Oh, I
heard you were cleared for advanced training.
Oh money penny Money penny I thought money penny was the one
on the phone If I can't Well, then I don't have much use for
you.
Oh, she was using the AI.
I thought, like, the AI was calling me.
Get the hell out of my Faraday cage.
Come on.
I'm funny, Ben.
I just remembered the money part.
I'm sorry.
I go by first name only.
I wouldn't really know where to begin.
Q?
You really should work on that infuriatingly secretive side
of yours.
Oh, but the computer was, yeah, the chat GPT was giving her
an info i see a bit over the top perhaps you just wait and
see oh we're gonna be cute what does q look like
oh my god that's a classic i'm sure q is waiting for you oh
and dr amicia my fault didn't mean to for a sign that says
tax him oh that's so cool meeting green oh my god guys i
scored a Sorry to meet, to have a meet and agree with Q.
Hey, Gary.
Yeah, I'm looking for my jaw.
Oh my god, guys, I got a meet and agree ticket.
Welcome to Q Branch.
What is the Q Lab?
MI6's internal R&D division.
We design customized field equipment for that extra edge.
I'm not getting a cyanide tooth if that's what you mean.
Cold War myth.
We prefer to keep you alive.
Then we're on the same page.
This Q person.
He's the head of branch.
Dapper-looking chap.
But don't let appearances fool you.
The man's mind is as sharp as the crease in his trousers.
It could be a spy gadget.
It could be an invisible pencil and a invisible notebook.
They'll never get caught that way.
Whoops.
I wasn't finished talking to you.
Where might I find Q?
Down past the central platform.
Here we meet Gary.
Oh my gosh.
I met Gary.
Are they testing out?
Ready?
Hit me
I like how you Bro didn't even wear his goggles I think he's
deaf now Bro didn't even wear his fucking headphones Hey
careful with that Yeah, careful Sonic Pulse is not a toy
It's really fun It's over here Look at all these cool
gadgets We need to increase the payload.
We want an oil slake, not a trail.
The payload size is permanent.
You're in it.
You're in eye damage.
Let me try and tweak the parameters.
Give it a shot.
Now it's her.
She's a prototype.
What did she do?
Oh my god, look at all these sick gadgets.
Can't talk right now.
Busy.
Well, let me read your newspaper.
The London Bulletin, the front page news is about the
diplomat tension between the uk and slovakia a disastrous
m50 sting operation in which the slovakian ambassador was
unintentionally shot and killed oh we're not very good at
our jobs according to the specs it goes below oh it's a
drone got it i can't believe we're being paid for this taser
drones huh taser drones the latest in automated building
security a lot harder to dodge than the cctv camera plus
cctv cameras don't usually zap you true this one is a
special commission from the foreign secretary's office
apparently they've had several break-in attempts very
pro-tech that secretary bright yeah well you lead you follow
or you get out of the way wait is that cute wait he's so old
no oh he's old and not him
Oh, no, they failed it.
Q is not in the last James Bond movie.
No, you can't.
Still a few clicks to iron out.
The smoke released too early this time.
Probably the proximity sensors need recalibrating.
Run diagnostics.
Yes, mom.
That's cool in your talk.
Oh wait, who's she?
Bridget.
I hear you like to blow things up.
Don't we all?
What can I do for you?
Have you seen Q?
He's out in the main lab.
Thanks.
Something tells me this place does not feature on the
security budget.
We have a sister agency under the defense ministry
responsible for the development of emerging technologies for
use by the military.
Their funding budget is effectively limitless.
Only been one young Q in the movies.
That's the one movie I watched.
New office.
New era.
The 00s got decommissioned more than a decade ago.
And Q branch along with it.
A lot of what you see just came out of deep storage.
Oh.
Getting the band back together.
Are we starting this?
That's why we're rebooting the WL program.
I don't know the half of it.
I see.
So we're bringing back the Q branch for the double...
program.
Guessing this is more than a lamp, correct?
What's that?
That's a stun grenade?
And it produces a blinding flash that'll give you just the
edge you need in a close quarter fight.
You can also trigger it.
Why can't I see anything?
Did that?
Yeah, he said press twice.
I wanted to test hysteria.
You know, I was just testing his theory.
Beautiful ride.
Any chance I could take it for a spin?
Depends.
Are you biometrically matched?
I'm guessing no.
In that case, absolutely not.
Worth a shot.
But you've been on forever.
What are you working on?
Oh, it's this robotic arm.
What is this?
That's me.
The chat from the Iceland incident.
yeah i heard they were bringing you into the fold i was just
delighted what you did and without proper training truly
remarkable who could have who turned on the lab my friend
packs why can't i see anything i don't know why hold your
head high bond i mean that thanks it's all right they have
health insurance right it covers it it should be five
they've come a long way since artillery on st nicholas web
ceo web industries uk's most prominent tech company i want
to make sure he's you know i want to make sure his
technology works what is he oh my god is that pc
what is that that must be a new 6080.
i guess that's my fault yeah we're not barbarians but they
Who could have?
Yeah, I can't believe M16 staff turned it on.
I really need to.
That's where all the RAM went to.
Holy shit.
No two ways about it.
Tremendous design.
Barely any recoil.
What's next?
No recoil?
Q has a blueprint for a fountain pen version.
Think big.
Go small.
Oh my god, I'm sold.
Oh no you don't.
Oh?
Hands off, Bond.
Sorry.
oops sorry didn't sorry i thought there was a bug on the
button i'm sold give me 20 million of that and we'll sell it
to all the other countries have you been down to deep
storage oh i tell you some of this gold war stuff is
ingenious for its time i found this 60s era diesel powered
jet pack complete death drop terribly sorry i'm just trying
to get through oops oh i interrupted here where were we oh
yes yes have you been down to storage i tell you some of
this gold war stuff is ingenious for its time i found this
60s era diesel powered jetpack complete death trap of course
i wouldn't strap it on to save my life but still well yeah
full marks for trying how is this a notice for internal
workshop on immersive vr hosted by dr selena tam the head of
taxon oh that i needed to meet her too
I love that we get to look at all the gadgets.
But my personal favorite has got to be the exploding conch.
Exploding conch.
Oh, I'm the beach?
Supposedly tried to make his hair and beard fall off.
So he'd lose the respect of his men.
Honestly, how the cousins managed to stay ahead of us for so
long is beyond me.
Manifest destiny.
Must be.
I like that.
I love spy gadgets.
They're so cool.
Glad we can, like, I'm glad we can, like, interact with
them.
And, like, look at all the gadgets that they make.
Alright, what's over here?
Well, I can sit down.
Not just any couch.
Wait, this couch is a gadget?
How did he get back out?
With great difficulty.
Okay, then.
Wait, oh, there's...
Oh!
It's the Danny DeVito couch!
It's the summer in Philadelphia couch!
He's in the couch!
He gets to be sad on.
What a guy.
Okay.
I guess, oh wait, who's that?
Is that Selina?
I think not Selina.
James Bond.
I've been monitoring you quite closely.
The last time someone told me that, I had to leave the
country in some haste.
Oh, which country?
Which time?
Dr. Selina Tan.
I'm in charge of tactical simulations.
My department specializes in performance management and
skill development.
I've been working with Thayer on a prototype based on the
ice and...
incident once the system is operational i'd very much like
you to have a go i'm not sure ever been one for nostalgia
you're intrigued admit it come and see me after training i
promise you won't be disappointed all right i guess we can
finally talk to q hey q oh my god's little mustache okay
wait wait i think it's doable i'm looking for someone called
q And you found him.
I think I can make you work.
Step through here, please.
Go away.
Now, look into these.
They get it.
Hold still.
Eyes open.
What was that?
It's your lenses.
You need a little time to calibrate, so you won't see
anything just yet.
Ah, interesting.
What?
right follow me i have something for you
pick one i already have a watch oh you do may i see it oh my
god even how he i'm sorry even the way he points i see it
he's a little zesty
oh my god that was my father's watch yeah
Now choose one.
What if that watch is like fucking my dad bought it from you
or some shit?
They all oh, I guess it's the arm band It's the front okay
midnight maroon Navy blue dawn gray winter gray.
I would go with winter gray stylish pick I do believe
there's hope for you yet You're the first recruit to receive
one give it a moment to calibrate What's the word?
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
Hold alt to enter Q lens mode.
Oh my gosh, my eagle vision.
Use the watch to turn off the two lamps on the table in
front of you.
Oh, that's cool.
I like that.
It has a variable active range and a 360 reach angle.
To be honest, we haven't tested it to its limit yet.
Why don't you give it a try?
But Papa, thank you.
Give it a super chat.
Thank you.
Hacked off.
I like it.
Don't change a thing.
It must still be set to my profile.
Well done, though.
Let me reset your watch to field mode.
If it runs out of power mid-mission, you can recharge it
from whatever electrical devices are available.
So I'll just need a battery on the bench there.
Montgomery, we need a cleanup over here.
It's battery powered?
Oh, man.
Q, what's on your mind?
penny what's her story grew up in Hammersmith studied
computer science at Imperial College London she turned down
an illustrious career in the private tech industry to
instead join SO 50 take a government job she was tapped for
MI6 after she exposed a domestic terrorist cell incidentally
I believe she's the one who recommended you for the program
here I thought we were friends what can you Tell me about M.
Career diplomat with postings in Jordan, Iran, Iraq, and
Indonesia.
No one's top pick but an easy compromise.
Uncontroversial, non-partisan, dependable.
Someone who wouldn't rock the boat.
I dare say a few MPs choked on their biscuits when she
relaunched the long-shuttered 00 program on her first day of
office.
M.
She's ambitious.
They have quantum computers, but they still need batteries
for a watch.
It creates her and it will confess to anything.
Precisely.
Created Thayer.
You just showed me the lady of the house.
Who created her?
Oh, no.
Computers are not my field.
Quantum or otherwise.
Thayer was developed by web industries.
The AI company.
Oh.
Is Thayer going to be evil?
Their partnership with the government goes back more than
the same.
Is web trying to get like government secrets?
Is that foreshadowing?
an explosive pen when all the agents are snug behind the
well they have made by a third by third party that seems
pretty suspicious the asset in iceland oh it's about time
someone levels with me the asset as you put it was an ai
being evil no never a sophisticated cloud-based data network
obtaining it would have provided us a unique back door deep
into a rival's intelligence apparatus right i'm sure it
crashed my evil detector is going off right now Raiden's
chip malfunction.
Its owners believe it burned up during reentry, but Thayer
pieced together the facts from a number of disparate data
points.
A Siberian social media post of Norwegian weather satellite.
Quite remarkable, really.
How did Arrowhead find out?
We found spyware on a member of the extraction team's phone.
These modern criminals...
Yeah, my bond senses are tingling right now.
Shotgun approach.
Then they sit back and they wait for a boon.
I tell you, Bond, you picked one hell of a time to become a
secret agent.
better not keep money penny waiting good to meet you
likewise all right oh what's this sabotage turn on you turn
on so many things sabotage
turn on wake up
let's see does that mean wait what's that over there Oh my
god.
Does that mean I have new toys to play with?
Wait, what?
Can't do anything to it.
Why glow?
I guess I haven't unlocked that feature yet.
Oh, it's locked.
Is there anything I can turn on?
Anything I can sabotage?
Okay.
I knew that.
What are things I can do?
Wait, I haven't talked to you.
Wait, is that Gary?
Hey, Gary?
Why are you doing back here?
Is there anything else?
No gadget I can sabotage right now?
I'm a saboteur?
Guess what else I found in deep storage?
A tiny one-person submarine.
Oh, I thought I could turn that missile on.
What are you doing?
Apologies.
Whoops, sorry.
Sorry, I tripped.
Oh, I guess it's just the arm.
I can't turn anything else on.
It's dokey-proofed.
They dokey-proofed the gadgets.
They gave me the power.
Yeah, what can I do with this power?
Nothing.
What's the point?
I'm stuck in customs.
Customs.
they know we're mi6 we're not mi6 we're universal exports
apparently you knew i was coming they turned it all off can
i come through it gave me the hacking ability to and not be
able to hack about recruit bond still waiting on deliveries
that should have been here weeks ago but we're more or less
up and running sounds good might give it a try all right
what else is over here the shooting range oh i should be
able to be there next right i feel like they're gonna lead
me here to test out guns you're like the amount of damage
you have done so you have to work for free at m16 for the
rest of your life i told i'm doing for the passion all right
we're ready if you're ready to leave i'll brief you on
advanced training the lab is now safe from dokey m.i6 is
setting you up in safe houses for the next six months you're
with crescent and monroe so we're not going back to malta i
show you this and you want to go back to bunk beds the kill
for did i pass but yes you'll be going back and forth
between mi6 and malta for advanced training when in london
you'll just have to slum it in bay's water i'm
working for exposure
oh stephen bright oh foreign secretary bright bond i was
just dropping off a few boxes for
Whoa.
What the fuck?
This place is sweet.
This corner is just perfect for my training gear.
Now go.
Get settled.
Your room's down the hall on my left.
Damn.
This place is nice.
Paid all by the British tax dollars.
Isn't that great?
A Morova's grandfather, legendary, S.A.S.
officer.
Oh, and he called me a Nepo hire.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
That guy was projecting.
I'm the Nepo hire.
This is where your tax money goes, guys.
I knew he was fucking projecting.
than my last flat yeah this is a big ass bathroom put
together yeah see this see this bigger than the british flat
and your tax money goes to it
two netbook babies i would like a refund foreign secretary
bright is your dad okay they're both netbook kids how
oh my god a gift from from l from lopez amour a gift from
christina's money but no no no tax oh yeah and the british
tax dollars are paying for their flat right now am i the
only non-nepo kid here and bond is an orphan this game was
rigged from the start the legacy hires this is kingsman
right now where did you get here about 40 minutes ago when
you're already plastering the wall are we the only one
that's poor notes and a mess in 40 minutes i'm impressed
shut it you're starting sound like monroe listen if i'm
getting taxed at least one of my country's special agents to
be tripped out and said tripped by a paid actor that's a
paid actor right there that's chris that's christina on her
alt account really yeah how monroe makes decisions is a
mystery to me the keys on my desk all right why do you pick
this room think this room is the best one facing east
releasing endorphins in the morning cold in the evening and
not facing the streets the bathroom is right next door of
course the pipes and the drains are that's a good fit that
my tax dollars paid for who wouldn't besides i really like
the color thanks for the designer these are the designer
items my fellow brits Oh, that's cute.
All right.
Let's go to my room.
Oh, this is me then.
Oh my god.
It's pretty sweet.
Okay, this one room is bigger than my apartment.
Like, what the fuck?
Yeah, this does beat the bunk beds.
Bro, are you hacking my laptop again?
Stop it.
All right.
Watch is too cool.
Really?
What are you up to?
Trying to read my messages, you creep.
Studster 555 wants to see you again.
Damn.
I mean it, stop it.
You're going to break it.
Find something else to hack, please.
All right, all right.
Oh, we both have hacking watches.
boys someone needs to unpack the kitchen what's for dinner
leave it let's head out and sell this letter from greenway
information about advanced training the crews will be
traveling between malta and m16 for the next six six months
okay my watch is fully charged right now so we should be
fine not bad hey it's all right for a little while i suppose
oh my god is that louis vuitton I wonder who's Louis Vuitton
soon.
I like how they all came with like 20 suitcases and I have
one duffel bag.
That's like all my belongings.
That's all my...
Is that really it?
Did I only pack one fucking duffel bag?
Is that...
Yeah, that's really...
Yep, that's really it.
My entire life is in that duffel bag.
A little tongue, yeah.
up here thank you for the raid i think you thank you i've
got a great stream all right here we go now you're here you
can help us settle something all i got hey monroe not a nepo
baby bond you'll be the judge what do you say this grotesque
prestige of hyper masculine tropes or this piece massively
commanding negative space with a quiet intensity well you
know what i'm gonna yeah Do you want the sick-ass martial
arts poster or what the fuck this is?
Fucking course the sick-ass martial arts poster my man Sorry
Chris hyper masculinity is the way to go Inspiring knew I
could count on you mate if that poster goes up here your
shoes go in your room Monroe those two things are completely
unrelated All right, we got our poster.
Right is right, exactly.
Hell yeah.
Oh, I still have to talk to you.
I think she'll like me.
All right.
You didn't care to tell me your dad's the foreign secretary.
Actually, no.
You're asking a guy which one's cooler.
Kendra, thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a great stream.
There's nothing just about being Cressida.
Nice one, Bond.
Work on your subtlety and I'm sure you'll pass social
engineering with flying.
colors all right let's go eat thank god it's only so hard to
get decent indian just around the corner there's just enough
time before we head back to it's like the playground thing
the meaner she is that she is the more she's into me i'm
fine james by February oh it's been two months it's been a
month now
always do the unexpected it's the first rule of spycraft
task is simple go in and get the flag no lethal forces
allowed unless the opponent has intent to kill this may not
be real guns but we still play by those rules is that
understood bond your first president of monroe will be your
radio support try not to embarrass yourself i'm ready What's
our strategy?
We'll just have to wing it, won't we?
Greenway emphasize our code of conduct.
Do the unexpected.
Nobody can predict me.
Natural thinking and all that.
With that watch, you'll run circles around those grunts.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm always doing the unexpected.
Good luck.
Here we go.
You see it.
What are you waiting for?
The gate to open?
Must be part of the test.
Use your watch bond.
BAM!
Entering now.
Here we go.
This is it, Bond.
Get that flag.
Remember you're training me.
You've got this.
Wait, where's my...
Good thinking staying low.
Got him out of the way first.
Seems okay now.
Six months of this?
Yes, please.
Left route.
My choice exactly.
I don't know, you saw me, right?
Remember our code of conduct.
Don't shoot.
Absolutely necessary.
Hey, if it works, it works.
Go for it, Bond.
Okay.
All right.
Does he know?
Oh, shit!
How did he know?
What?
Do you think he knows?
There we go.
Situation contained.
How do I get my gun out?
I want to start shooting.
Hello.
I have a gun in my pocket!
Give me a sec.
I want to start shooting.
Rules of engagement.
Better not.
Pussy?
Don't forget the rules of engagement.
Oh my god, it's actually full of stealth.
Never give in.
That's it.
Never heard you come in.
That's fucking right.
Even if I can't kill, I'll still kill.
You should turn it off.
You should really turn it off, bro.
Who was that?
Guess we'll never know.
We'll never know who the fuck that was.
Fuck you.
Oh, back to you.
He knows.
There you go.
Situation contained.
You made it to the tower.
Now get to it.
Who was that?
Is that?
Who is what?
That's fucking right.
Situation contained.
Yeah.
I guess we won't will never know who that was Ammo crates I
mean sure BAM Containing the situation I don't even know
where I'm going Containing all over the place Where's the
flat what was the objective again?
I wonder what the objective was.
I can't do anything with the cement.
And they get up from there.
But how do I contain the situation?
Maybe I pick him up here?
Stay there.
And now spawn.
We're going to get a nice siege.
Containing!
Containing the situation!
Here we go.
Bam!
Contained.
Situation contained.
See, it's that easy.
I'm containing.
Alright.
Get you out of the way.
That's it, mate.
Oh, wait.
Don't not back up.
There's a madman.
No!
I'm containing!
I'm not even taking the shot.
Shoot the kill.
Do not shoot!
Are you ready for contact?
We are engaging a hostile.
No, you're not!
Okay.
You people need to work on your communication.
Situation contained.
No guns.
I know.
It's all right.
It's been contained.
Do you think they know?
You think they know?
All right, it's fine.
I don't think they knew.
There
are so many ways to do that, Klaus.
No excessive force.
Oh, I used up my battery.
Yes!
I'm struck!
Rules of engagement!
License to kill!
Finally!
That's it!
Now you're in my territory!
Where are the rest of them?
I am now licensed to kill!
Give me a sec!
No guns.
I know.
Where are the rest of them?
Self is now an option.
Where are they?
I know you're still alive.
Oh,
I can't shoot them.
Where's the rest of them?
Where are you?
Situation contained.
She's playing Apex.
There we go.
I told you I can contain the situation.
Look at, okay, but those headshots are sick though.
Guys, those are some sick headshots.
I had to make sure I contained it all.
Where?
You saw me go, pop, pop, pop.
Saw those flicks?
You're on him, crack.
Alright, now we get the flag.
they're impressed.
Oh my god, they're so proud, guys.
Look at too easy.
The dokey way.
I told you.
Unexpected.
Just light work.
Bum-bum.
Establishing a baseline is the first thing they'll want to
do.
We're on April now.
Answer truthfully.
What's your name?
James Bond.
How old are you?
26?
Now watch this.
You don't like me, do you?
God, Jesus.
Live.
Watch.
Clear spike.
Now if you can muster the courage, unlike young Bond here,
it's always best to go with the truth, as long as it doesn't
jeopardize your mission objective or sensitive information.
Let's try again.
Do you think telling me you don't like me will affect my
ability?
to judge you objectively.
Based on our past experience.
Yes.
In other words, you think I'm incompetent.
Damn!
Do you miss your parents?
None of your business.
But you would agree that being orphaned at a young age has
left you rudderless and unable to finish anything
meaningful.
What?
No.
Are you offended?
You think I've overstepped?
You do realize that the people who put you in that chair in
real life...
Yeah, he just docks me like that?
Dig in.
Oh, does that say secret Indian?
What a restaurant name.
Oh my god, draw me like one of your French girls.
Yeah, he was rage-baiting me.
Oh, yes, it was very dangerous.
Bond.
We're waiting.
Look at me go.
I'm starting to...
Oh!
My man!
Whoa!
The secretary!
Oh my god!
I'm doing it.
Maybe not.
Fine.
Maybe don't press the button.
Is that an HR violation?
My man!
I am.
calibrate what's your name crescent of bright eye color pale
blue gray okay fire the training exactly it's probably the
barn training hawkies crest ready here we go how old are you
52 how the hell do you do that try something harder i was
crescent does it bother you to be yes i freaking killed my
parents are seven
Yes!
That's right, Nepo baby.
Ask about her mom.
Your mother would be devastated to hear you say that, Kress.
She spends every waking hour paving your way through life.
I'm curious, doesn't that make you doubt your achievements
sometimes?
My spiritual journey has taken me to a place where the words
like mother and achievements are meaningless.
Nothing.
How is that possible?
You have to try harder to trip her up, Bond.
Ah.
And tell me, Cressida, did I see you checking out Monroe at
the fridge this morning?
What?
I...
Yes!
No, that is not fair.
Oh!
I'm the third wheel!
Wait!
Got him!
These phones do more than just...
Yeah, but it's the super lie detector.
That's different.
It's the spy lie detector.
And load up from the chemicals on the workbench.
Can't wait.
Come on guys, try it out.
Alright, my dart phone.
Found a chemical resource?
Oh, it's over there.
Come on, Bond.
Oh my god, I'm the wingman.
Ronson, step into the red square.
Bond, step into the blue circle.
Well, this is going to suck.
I'm the third wheel yet again.
Sorry, Ronson.
Doesn't it suck to be a roommate of a couple, though?
I feel like that shit is awkward.
Nausea, dizziness, and disorientation.
The target's balance is affected, making it impossible for
them to remain standing in one place.
Perfect for when you need someone out of your way.
Oh, shit.
It's not possible.
Correct.
Given your current inability to listen to my guidance, it is
not.
Bond, you're up.
You get there, mate.
I don't know.
I need some air.
You can't control the target, Nimro, but you can learn to
control the target.
Oh, that's slow motion.
Sounds simple enough.
Oh, I do.
Oh.
What?
I'm pressing E.
Tap E while aiming with the focus.
Hello?
Where's my E?
Okay.
you skill or pure dumb luck let's find out
again also not gonna lie i feel like it was just a license
to kill i'd finish these so fast like this like i was like
oh pop pop pop pop they're all dead
right i'm impressed i know guys it's not the bomb way early
day tomorrow catch the flag but it's not the bond way
suggest you get some rest I remember when Sundays were
Sundays yeah you're not supposed to just kill people hey
listen why don't we just take tomorrow off I wish I'm
serious we go get the flag now have a well-deserved rest
tomorrow but she that's actually not a bad idea what you
want to do this it's not painful this time they're real yeah
but they're the bad guys I can still be a secret agent if
they're all dead because there's no witnesses clean up crew
just has to do overtime to clean up They're going to stand
there all night.
Leave them to me, boys.
Apeces in.
Let me know when you're through.
Oh, it's the honeypot.
We're honeypotting.
Come on, Bond.
Listen, I know you guys don't like to be humiliated on the
courses, but if you choose to see through our people, you
believe this girl?
Piss off.
Okay, I'm just messing with you.
I am serious about something otherwise.
It's silly, really.
So we just wanted to reach out.
over
here all right we need to get past if we want to find the
flag okay I'll go around the side see if I can distract them
check what I didn't see how did you okay V dealer try night
takes queen if that's you Bennett I'm gonna stick this night
somewhere you won't like it
nice nice okay let's split up i'll go this way we need intel
on the flag's location asap on it keep in touch all right
teamwork makes the dream work
oh hello hey what are you doing um hey listen greenway's
birthday's coming up and we're throwing him a little thing
just spreading the word yeah we're just telling everybody
about the birthday party when was the last time you were
invited party with the spies didn't see it get out down here
do you think i'm just gonna let you leave no survivors
having a party without us a bit insulted any word from your
two friends nah still out they just don't make sas troopers
like in my there is no party side bro across the compound
that looks like a good place to start sounds like you boys
are enjoying your little game yeah so you think you can
leave let's see if they go all the way across gosh okay i
can go oh let's get that love groups of guards whoops uh
could i just have my baltic brown granite workshop from home
phone in great equality i wish you i'm gonna break your nose
you think they know
you're in it now bond certainly yeah nope situation
contained
situation contained all right let's do let's bluff hey guys
you this no paraphernalia sent me to check for readiness
looks good up here don't worry about me anyone for when my
six come up here they'll regret it so i see as you are
period jesus look at that oh hello
cat got your tongue right oh shit oh shit We're...
Situation contained!
Situation is so contained!
I'm containing the situation!
It's so contained right now!
Oh shit!
I'm containing so hard!
Oh my gosh Oh I'm okay
Okay I didn't think I thought I had more bluff I will admit
I will I will admit I thought I had more bluff Does this
look contained right now You've been contained I will say I
did make a little oopsie there okay okay now I know all
right it's fine guys watch this
okay and then and then I contained the situation hey guys I
think he's unconscious and before you ask it wasn't me see
you to get acquainted i
told you i have contained the situation
oh he's drunk all right nothing to worry about guys just
overheard a couple of troopers talking about the flag it's
on the top floor of the back building meet me up there on my
way
what is he just why is he just standing there all right that
contract other guys take it a bit of a kip let's grab this
real quick okay now we have enough okay He said it's like
above us.
So...
Open the door.
Is it across?
Am I not across yet?
Where am I?
Wait a minute.
Okay, it's up, up.
Okay, how do I get up, up?
How do I get up, up?
Okay, I'm going to keep crawling.
Oh, that's how I get up.
up all right top floor I'm tried oh never mind oh fuck do I
go up six months and if anyone was to find out I was talking
to you lot I've been off no problem maybe maybe it's here no
I can't get up there oh there we go I see it
what you worth way more than over that you must have to be
thorough i suppose it'll be down to us to find him a new one
let's see how hello thank god her just call ended you
sabotage that real quick the good thing is call ended just
in time so try to figure out how to go up up i think they'll
see me maybe here
Yeah, we're up up now.
There we go.
Just here.
Oh.
Stop scratching your ass and get moving.
This is really weird.
That's good.
Oh, to check that.
Can you see me?
Oh,
he's sick now.
He's sick.
Oh.
Let's see now.
Watch this.
Idiot.
All right.
Hey, guys.
Huh?
Hey, everybody.
There's an intruder in the lower levels.
but we didn't hear keep your ears open and you might next
time yeah stupid yeah get distracted let me enter the door
and look at that that's how you contain the situation
dragons
i know i'm such a good spy
got it right here that's how you do it I've got a plan thank
you.
Thank you.
I know
Take note everyone Made that guy sick for nothing through
the love of the game
Did it just cuz I can
Wait, it's a time wait, where's my gun though?
There's too many of them Sit red.
We're screwed.
Thanks, mate.
Things just got sticky.
Main door eggs.
It's not really an option just now.
Oh, shit.
Meet me at the backside doors.
Can't.
When Rose in trouble.
Block the door.
Ah, circle around and meet you there.
See you in there.
They won't know.
Yeah.
Oh, it's over here.
Alright.
Fine, stop climbing.
Okay, there we go.
oh my god am i not allowed to fucking okay i need to find a
hole there you go am i not allowed to jump down from here
are you serious you can jump down at anything else but fuck
that
all right like really that's where i draw the line am i
supposed to help monroe that's fine he'll be fine.
Yeah, you're not going to make it to the dock.
This edge.
Any chance you can go around and pick me up.
That could be the right.
That's brilliant fight.
Get out!
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
They're like, fuck, that's too high, apparently.
I will pick Monroe up.
What's your location, Monroe?
Just pin the root for you.
Good call on the boat, Kress.
I owe you one.
You can add it to the tab.
Glad to hear you're all safe.
Could you get a move on?
Can we get me?
We're trying to find you, Monroe.
I need to hear how every S.A.S.
in the compound suddenly got alerted to our presence.
The rogue?
You take that one.
Can't talk right now.
We will be served.
Christ, they're really going at it.
Bond, go!
Where?
Where is he?
Oh, there he is.
Oh, he's at the bridge!
John!
Coming in a bit close there.
No worries me.
All the time in the world.
He's gonna die, isn't he?
He's gonna...
He's gonna die on our first mission, isn't he?
New course.
Tougher opposition, tighter deadline.
So be smart.
Fastest win gets extra credits.
Yes, what is it, Bond?
First rule of spycraft.
Always do the unexpected.
And what about it?
We followed it, sir.
They're going to kill him off, aren't they?
They're trying to make us bond with him.
Get it?
Yeah, let's make us bond with him.
Get close with the group.
And then they're going to kill him off.
grab your coat we're going out don't tell me tea and
cucumber sandwiches you wish come on make us too comfortable
feel like we have a family and then and then we're gonna
become orphans again just like that is to everything not MI6
active Can't fault their timing
Found family Lost once again Is doomed, yeah Alright
Yeah James found a new family Guys And then they're gonna
take it away from him To remind him that Spy lives are short
Go back to the bar
What's supposed to do?
Can't talk.
I've been instructed to wait for my contacts.
Aren't you supposed to be meeting someone?
Yeah, by the bar.
Then what are you doing here?
Go.
Here's the bar.
Everything's so dark.
Working out a strategy.
Now, now, Bond.
We aren't past training yet.
I might not be able to top Cresta scores, but I plan to beat
yours.
Better get going if you don't want to fall behind.
And if you want to go on real missions next, this is the
time to prove our strength.
Uh-oh.
No kissing.
I can't find happiness.
You can't hide it.
No kissing.
Please, enough space for God.
Pardon me.
Where the fuck's the bar?
Oh, I found the bar.
Hello.
Is this my contact?
The epithelium oxypetalimony blossoms at night.
She's like, what?
Yeah, she's like, what the fuck?
I'm sorry.
Hey, how can you be so sure I'm not the one you want, yeah?
We only just met.
What the hell do you think you're doing?
Leaving.
Excuse me.
Hey, I'm not finished with you.
Leave it, Gav.
Leave it.
Come on, come on.
Let's buy me a drink.
Maybe it's him.
The epiphyllum oxypetalum only blossoms at night.
And only for a single night.
Oh, I did it.
There's a package for you in the gents.
Watch it in private.
X marks the spot.
Right.
Call me a pint of lager, will you?
I get this girl whatever she likes.
Damn.
Watch it.
I prefer smoky mezcal cocktails, but they're not in the yard
here.
Even though he's smoked, he has a job to do.
He still has enough time to Riz.
And a smoked old-fashioned for the lady.
Come in right up.
Where's the bathroom?
I'm not gonna move.
Who's this guy?
Sorry, I need to get by.
Why is he yellow?
Can you point me to the gens please over there by the
entrance all right it's over there Oh, it's over there Why
is he barking?
Hey No No No No All right He wants to party too He heard the
music night not bad you're right pretty good oh not yet i'll
leave it that you yeah blonde salt in the upstairs bar she
got me don't know hey guys she's in the downstairs you know
saw that picture of like the one guy that goes between the
two guys goes to the empty urinal that's between two guys
yeah i'm one of those guys i know what are you doing Don't
keep the broke code!
Yeah, she doesn't know the etiquette.
Do not break the code!
Yeah, that's me.
MI6 has identified a leak from the trade ministry.
We've narrowed our suspects to Three secretaries, Rick
Bolthorpe, Alice Weatherall, and Joshua Pike, all at the
club this very evening.
Your job is to identify the culprit.
Bond, you'll be teaming up with Nash and Singh to focus on
Pike.
Keep this device on you and get up close.
It will enable Singh to access Pike's phone.
Best of luck.
All right.
Okay, I'll get to...
Singh, Nash, we're on Pike.
Already looking for him.
Let's do this.
All right.
Told you, I wasn't finished with you.
everyone else out oh he wants to fight me i'm sure you
wouldn't hear about me breaking the bro code to warn you i'm
pretty good no one chats up my girlfriend the man of
principles oh shit i'll let you have that one what the i'm
trying to carry i'm trying to look cool on my stream let me
look cool that's right be over here Give me a sec.
I need to break the urinal.
Give me a sec.
No, I need to take you to the other urinal.
Can I still break this, though?
Oh, I can't break all the urinals.
Nash.
Oh, you're all done.
Yeah.
Thanks, anyway.
What?
No, no, I just came to watch.
Listen, guys.
Pikes upstairs, but it's guest list only.
but I got the club blueprints and there are some backstairs
behind the bar how about the dance floor balcony that's an
access point yeah tab there's a few current objectives there
are hints use hints to discover opportunities progress okay
first I'll pick up is I track opportunities being tracked
and untracked tracking one opportunity often means that the
million options do not need to be completed choose
opportunity to track well Well, now she's single.
Balcony above the dance floor leads to the lounge.
Behind the bar.
Sneak past bar.
Found a final way.
You know what?
What do I want to do?
Let's do the balcony.
Balcony sounds fun.
Balcony's nice.
I go get a view.
Overlooking the dance floor.
I don't know Oh Just telling you It's an access point Okay
maybe See Backstairs is staff only I presume Right They're
in a storage area So don't get in trouble Get upstairs Bond
And Nash You find a good vantage point For observations
After you Bond
Oh that's why she's He's an agent Okay I know how to get to
Oh my god You're having a lot What's in my face Hey I'm
going are you in the list sorry this is that upstairs lounge
oh yeah i am just uh give me a second i'll be right back
supposed to be upstairs lounge or the side of the clock you
got some oh that's the charge of the cloak room you cheap
you cheap is that not it maybe you'll get a discount oh okay
i was gonna say i did it i was gonna say wait i did it it
was like that i thought it was that easy
Okay, so that's the stab that they get.
Okay, that's the bad way.
Is that the...
I don't know.
I just wanted to test it out.
Why is there like a...
Oh, can I like eavesdrop?
You got to come.
I even got you on the VIP list.
Free drinks in the upstairs lounge.
Of course I didn't.
Jones?
Jones!
Jones and you'll get the stamp all right I did it wait
that's it so I did not the other task wait Jacksepticeye
wait that's Jacksepticeye yeah names Jones Jones yeah gotcha
yeah there you go enjoy yourself mate that's him I recognize
it yeah now i see him top of the morning to you
what is that not the upstairs lounge where the fuck is the
upstairs this leads upstairs okay that's where the bar
entrance is i guess where the fuck's the upstairs lounge
oh god i don't like that
what are you doing here you need to get up Any tips?
Get a move on.
My fault, I'm tired.
Upstairs loud just upstairs, Doki.
That's literally the only stairs I see.
Where's your mark?
Monroe's on her.
Pike's upstairs.
But there's a guest list.
You better get on that list then.
Or get up some other way.
I need to focus here.
I got the stab.
There we go.
I found my own way.
Get past the guard.
Where could the guard be?
Hey, move, man.
That's the exit.
Where the fuck is?
Upstairs.
What are you doing?
I'm trying to figure out where upstairs is!
See that bartender!
Okay, oh there it is!
I see it!
Upstairs!
Oh yeah.
Got my staff.
Right past those bouncers boss.
Yep, that's me.
Is it here?
Oh, that's for the staff entrance.
You're on lookout.
Kingsley is the talker.
She's got our target wrapped around her little finger.
I'll be jumping in at her mark.
I've got to focus bond.
Good luck with Pike.
Where does the upstairs lounge go?
Oh, there you go.
Locate pipe.
There he is.
Get up close.
Just for the sake of it.
For the
love of the game.
But I believe we've identified him.
Wait, he... wait!
no no i gotta find find a way in though but he's so sick
though he's so i'm i'm here to help him he's so sick oh i'm
just part of the staff i'm right wait actually give me the
give me this give me a sec give me this and give me that
yeah I got an order got an order for him great our drinks
hang on is that a martini I didn't order that no one in
their right mind would and that one pineapple only
acceptable pineapple ever is on my he's one of those guys we
ordered don't be an ass crispin besides where's your sense
of adventure yes why don't you live a little crispin if
you'd excuse me yes but i deserve that you put in a bit of
an ladies and gentlemen data extraction complete good job
you did it celebrate where are you guys i'm up here on the
balcony on my way let's grab this Doink, my battery now.
Oh, God, I don't like too much trope, too much trope, too
much trope.
Okay, there you go.
I'm okay.
What a night.
I think we...
Listen, I just found something.
What?
We could unravel the whole network.
And how exactly would that play out?
Have they met before?
Uh, no.
First time.
Perfect.
monroe how about you intercept the meeting pretend to be
pike bond you make sure pike doesn't show any ideas our best
bet would be to stow him away somewhere oh my god it's too
much stroke close your eyes up here oh there we go by the
stairs to make sure pike doesn't slip down get rid of pike
all right trap location uh search for a solo spot to trap
pike on this floor oh my god He got closer.
All right.
I'm going to give him a little snack.
Give me a sec.
He got closer.
He literally ran up to my door.
It's like, did you not hear me?
All right.
Oh, I hate that.
Find the trap location.
Oh, right here.
Oh, that woman in my room door is acting up again.
Got stuck last night.
Sam spent nearly three hours in there before we even noticed
she was missing.
So there's a storage room.
I bet she wasn't happy about that.
Where is the storage room, though?
Whoops, sorry.
Uh, I'm leaving.
Where is the storage room?
Oh, it is over there.
Okay.
Oh, it was that easy.
This will do nicely.
I'm gonna make Pike follow me.
I'll tell him that there's a hot sexy lady in your area.
Hot single sexy ladies in your area.
But where is he?
He was sitting down here last time.
But where did he go?
I swear I saw him here.
what oh he's dancing excuse me hello change your plans come
with me who the hell are you your contact had to abort last
second I'm his replacement you want this deal to happen then
start walking okay okay I'll walk all right is he walking
just through here in here I'll you press
hold f to sabotage the door bottle service what pardon me oh
i mean that's one way to sabotage the door tell me you got
his phone first i've got you covered fried his sim time for
phase two bond meet me by the stairs at least he can drink
yeah i gave him a drink though you know I let him have a
drink not that much of a monster
all right let's go meet go meet chrisanda my nepo baby
chrisita now we just need monroe to scare the socks off her
so she calls her boss change of plans I just found a message
she's expecting someone tall dark and handsome that's me
it'll have to be one then that is me I've got eyes on our
girl 30 black She's behind the cloakroom.
No rest for the wicked.
Oh my god, it's time.
It's time the honeypot, guys!
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Leave room for Jesus.
Alright.
I found her.
Good.
You showed.
And I was just about to leave.
You're late.
Give her hell, okay?
We need her to call her handler.
The price is up.
I doubt that.
In fact, you're so hot for what I've got.
We need to talk price.
It just doubled.
Why do little men like you always do that?
You must know we won't play along.
I pressure.
Don't.
That's right.
I'm buying.
I also be more appreciative of my services.
God, you're serious.
I can call my guy, but trust me, it won't turn out well for
you.
Oh yeah?
Call him.
oh christ could we not do this you prefer her to me please
i'm leaving oh wait did i it up no stay what the and who the
hell are you acting all superior how does she get here how
about you put a leash on your girlfriend i'm my girlfriend
she's not my girlfriend damn right i'm not don't believe a
word he says Smooth, but such a liar.
Osshole, I'm done.
No!
If you go, the offer is up.
It's now or never.
Your call.
Shit.
Give me a few minutes.
I need to make a phone call.
I don't know who to talk to.
There's too much, too many women.
I didn't know I had options.
You want more money.
Done.
She's making the call.
What took you so long?
It's got complicated.
One at the time, women.
One at the time.
Girls, girls.
First to arrive gets extra credit.
It sure did take a while.
But I've always known those looks of yours that get us in
trouble someday.
I think he just sucks at turning down the keen ones.
You wouldn't know, Singh.
But it actually takes a lot of practice.
I'll give you some pointers one of these days.
There are too many options.
I'm sorry, guys.
TikTok.
What is already a lot?
Now you want me to multitask?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
What did I say?
This is a Christian club.
Marriage before kissing.
Alright, I'll go this way.
Guys, multitasking is really hard.
You're dead, man.
Oh, shit.
Man, if I cut in.
Monroe!
Don't.
he's definitely gonna die too many bonding moments with him
every time we see him it raises the probability up
oh my god did i kill him what the fuck was that oh my god i
think he's dead wait wait did i wait guys guys guys i think
He, I think he might actually be dead.
Wait, how do I block again?
I don't even remember.
Yeah, I think he might be super dead.
Where is he?
Where is the last guy?
Oh, Q is also the block.
Oh, Q, N is blocked and Perry.
I'd say there's still time for a pint.
What?
You think we passed?
Mission success?
I'm suspending training.
Effective immediately.
What?
Not too good?
The former 009 real name Reese Beckett.
Cut C-Time.
Oh shit.
Oh, is that why?
Oh, that must be why the old program got suspended.
Oh, what's so blower?
We gotta kill him.
And he intends to land it in and return for a full pardon on
one condition.
He will only talk to John Greenway.
I guess there really is someone for everyone.
And where do we come in, Mom?
Last time I checked cutting deals with traitors was not in
our playbook.
009 is a master infiltrator.
resourceful as he is paranoid thinking two steps ahead is
this man's idea of lazy to catch him we're gonna need eyes
everywhere consider this a field exam get your equipment and
cover stories from q money penny will fill you in on the
rest dismissed i'm gonna say i'm enjoying this game a lot i
really like the gameplay and the story so far it's very bond
like i mean it is a james bond game
to bring you along just a heads up right any advice hmm
doing what you're told might be a good start like there's
many ways to fuck up a game like this but I feel like
they've nailed it really well they really nailed a bond game
hmm the
only thing missing is more of honeypot missions We need
more.
Look, me Felling the Riz Was in character Because he's just
starting, guys.
He's just starting out as an agent.
You think he came out of the womb Full of Riz?
No, he earned it.
He built up the Riz, guys.
What did she say?
Greenway doesn't want me to come after last night.
Sure, yeah.
I missed the extraction deadline too.
I am going.
He still needs to level up.
Let's go see Q.
A rogue double O coming in from the cold.
Not bad for a first mission.
She said he's been alive in the first decade.
That roughly matches when the program was shut down, doesn't
it?
Yeah.
It does.
You think he caused that?
It could be.
Or it could just be timing deciding things.
I mean, Thayer was just integrated.
Perhaps the double O's didn't feel needed to the same extent
after that.
Any ounce of Q love?
In a moment.
Q-Lab.
Cover stories and field equipment.
This sure beats exams.
I wonder what he's got lined up for us.
I wouldn't mind that bike coming along.
Oh, I heard you were more into explosives.
Oh, that's true.
I am.
Yeah!
Basil knows what's up.
I'm the chairman.
I guess that'll be Greenway, right?
They did both run for the post.
Yeah, guys.
I'm building up to it.
a journey it's a character arc from riseless to full of ris
i have your cover story from q can't wait later mate any
idea what's in store for me no clue something dashing no
doubt this guy fashion photographer fearless war
correspondent adventurer archaeologist i'll see you in a bit
oh hey gary recruit bond i hear you got banned from the art
club on your first visit nicely done Not more of a lounge
lizard.
He's in queue.
He's in wearables.
Of course he is.
Did I hack anything?
Or did it dokeyproof everything?
Wait.
Who's that over there?
It's green.
That's not mean.
Oh, it just means I can talk to you.
I thought I could make her sick.
Wait.
Aw.
She's like, what are you looking at?
Wait, unless...
Oh, I'm not allowed to make anyone throw up, unfortunate.
They really did doky-proof this area.
Bond, congratulations on completing training.
I'm happy to tell you that Taksim is now up and running.
Care to try?
Sure.
I want to just check out Taksim.
What is it?
It's going to blow your mind.
is it a tactical simulator to my dream factory before you
start you must load up a simulation using the taxim console
we've just added some exciting new challenges to the oh do i
get upgrades for doing this the taxim console contains our
library of available sims there are several types of
missions available to you an escalation is a tactical trial
where each successful playthrough unlocks a new tier of
difficulty an operation tests your lateral thinking
requiring you to use your tools creatively to solve any
number of challenges completing simulations yields intel and
xp which oh yeah it does unlock more stuff all right
missions containing description and intel reward type and
number challenges to complete escalation of tears each tier
has its own reward higher tiers unlocked as preceding tiers
are completed okay but uh select the first
Oh, it's locked.
Never mind.
There are also tabs containing the challenges and
leaderboard for the mission.
Select, prepare missions to start playing, look around for a
bit more.
Which one is all about shooting?
I guess all of them are technically.
The leaderboards.
Oh my god.
Man-like frog.
I'm the only one that has ever played it.
I'm surprised.
I feel like I've got one more people be playing this.
I'm very surprised.
I didn't even thought more people would play this.
It's very fun.
Kid.
Let's game change.
Sure.
Let's get you sorted.
Come with me.
Up ahead is the simulation platform.
Oh.
The system taps into your Q lens and projects a virtual
space directly into your field of vision.
oh my god it's it's the classic tucks the platform turns in
all directions ensuring you remain in the center at all
times 360 treadmill he does remind me of eggs a bit and the
men's wear as always the devil's in the detail we find the
experiences more immersive when you dress the part something
tells me q is behind this however did you guess now pick
your outfit from the wardrobe your weapon from the firearms
console and your gadgets from the cart when you're ready
simply step onto the platform to begin the simulation okay
bond welcome we have a broad range of gadgets and firearms
available help yourself oh what are gadgets oh that's all i
get i guess i just have a watch wow she said we have all
sorts of gadgets but it's just one gadget so he lied okay i
don't have a silent still yet i don't have anything all
right that's cool all sorts of gadgets just to watch align
for a new look for every mission oh desert kingsington
gentlemen operated silent day of the oh i want the classic
tuxedo agent outfit funeral observant first class savannah
blue Okay.
Aye, aye, Captain.
This reminds me of...
What's that spy movie one?
With the one German guy and then the American guy.
The one with Henry Cavall in it.
This is what it reminds me of.
Oh, what's that?
Oh, also Archer, I guess.
Yeah, also...
What was it?
The one with...
Man from Uncle!
Yes!
This outfit reminds me of Man from Uncle right there with a
German guy.
And Archer.
Let's be Archer, actually.
Let me purchase Oh, I can buy more items.
Oh!
I don't have money.
I'm poor.
I'm sad.
I was so excited.
I was actually so excited.
I have zero dollars of everything.
Alright, let's go.
There goes nothing.
The poverty debuff.
The non-Nepo baby.
Oh, that's sick.
That's actually sick.
Knock, knock.
That's fucking right.
That's a pity.
Knock!
That's sick.
I can disarm them just like that.
Can I take his gun?
Or is it biometric?
I can.
Nice.
Knock!
Oh.
Whoops.
I got a little too excited.
I don't like the shotgun.
How am I...
How are they so tanky?
What?
Am I doing... Oh.
I'm supposed to lure them.
Right?
Wow, using focus.
How do I use focus for this?
Oh!
There we go.
knows.
I forgot about the focus attack.
Yay!
I got my clearance.
Hey, top 94% in the world.
Wait, we start sim.
I can do this faster.
I got a little confused.
Guys, I'm definitely gonna forget the controls in two weeks,
guys.
I'm a little scared.
I don't want to do this fast.
Boom!
Oh, shit.
Sorry.
I got too excited.
How did I fail?
Wait, what?
I shot him in the arm.
What I shot him in the art.
Oh, I killed him.
That's my bad.
I killed him Oops
That's my bad accidentally killed him
Whoops Should have read your job description
Give me your gun give
me your gun
Where are they?
Wait, what?
Did I not kill him?
Oh my god, I didn't kill him.
There you go.
I was like, what?
Where are they?
Nice.
It's a little...
It might not be as fast.
But... There you go.
Fast learner!
There we go.
Fast learner.
I was fast.
See, they said I was fast.
Look at that.
They gave me fast learner because I was pretty fast.
All right, here we go.
Next tier.
Okay.
No silent, reduced precision.
Double.
What is it?
They hit me!
Hit me!
All right.
Double leg shot.
Boop!
Situation contained.
There we go.
And then shot, focus headshot.
There you go.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh, where's that double leg shot?
Where are you?
That's right.
Now I need to do a shot this arm.
License to kill.
What else did I unlock?
That's it?
I did so much!
That's right.
Look at that.
Oh, that's a pass.
I passed.
Top 27%.
Alright, what's next?
Keep giving me these tasks.
I got by my tuxedo.
I gotta look cool as hell.
Oh, this is easy.
I need I need a gun
Oh shit Oh shit Oh fuck
Okay that guy had a lot of armor That guy might have been
like armored of I had zero shields.
I'm 1 HP.
He had like 800 shields, a gun, and a lot more than I
expected.
Oh, maybe not him first.
Oh, shit.
That doesn't matter, I guess.
Um, um, oh, that's awkward for me.
I need a gun really badly.
radio is playing.
Jump!
Oh my god, I can't jump.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is so bad.
Oh my god, this is so bad.
Oh, where am I?
Where can I get a gun?
Maybe there's a gun in here.
Guys, I just need one gun.
There we go.
What?
okay no ammo okay all right maybe standing out in the open
was not was not the best idea
maybe i i shouldn't have stood there on high ground being
like look at me there i am look at me i'm here No, you
don't.
Alright, now I can shoot.
Oh my god, I don't know why I thought.
I don't know why.
That was my bad.
I'm just gonna assume.
There we go.
Give me that gun.
I need our gun.
Alright.
There we go.
It's fine.
We're so healthy.
Oh my god.
One more shot.
Ha ha ha.
Get out of here.
There we go.
Ease.
see.
See?
Not too bad.
Look at that.
All I had to do was just keep shooting.
First try.
With my sniper shotgun.
Alright.
I did it.
Is there more Sims?
Is there any more?
I completed that.
Oh, there's another one.
You learned how perfect close combat.
I can use a gun with this, right?
Oh, wait, there's more stuff to un... Oh, wait.
Completed, completed.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Four or less.
Eliminated Tier 2 or four or less.
No gadgets.
No gadgets equipped.
Uh, what about firing a shot?
Bro, fuck it.
Use four different gadgets.
Shotgun, driver, wearing a chauffeur, pistol, three
takedowns, chemist, grab and rush two enemies off the ledge.
Okay, do I have enough, though?
Do I have enough for clothes?
There's so many stuff to unlock.
I need I'm only level two I mean
I guess I'll buy that there's nothing else I can buy oh I
can get a shockwave camera
wait I won't write that yes please What's my gadget upgrade?
I don't have any of this.
I'm so broke.
Oh my god, there's AirPods.
What the fuck is the AirPods?
Oh, it's a mine.
But I don't have that yet.
I guess I'll buy the SMG.
And a shotgun?
Fuck it.
Let's go.
Alright, guys.
I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
But...
I look at this cool new...
This cool new wardrobe.
I want to be a captain.
I'll be right back.
Guys, I gotta use the bathroom.
Dad's here to hang out.
Because he realized I ate food.
So now he's like, ooh, where are the scraps?
Oh my, I have to be level...
That's... I'm so... I'm sad.
I'd be level 12 to be cool.
12 clearance so i can look cool but i want to be cool now
all right he left he's like she didn't drop any food all
right i gotta grind to be cool i guess i got earned the drip
i need a level 12 clearance to be dripped out not worthy
Alright, I don't know how to tie my own tie yet.
I'll do ask my mom at the time I die.
Alright, let's do the close combat.
Oh,
shit.
Oh.
Okay.
Well, since this is a simulation, it looks like I'm just
punching nothing.
I feel it.
I bet you.
Oh, there's combos to this, too.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
One, two.
What?
I'm M doing it.
One, two.
There we go.
I'll rip you a new one.
Okay, but he's blocking.
Two.
I'm trying to do the gun punch.
But he always makes...
Okay, maybe I'm clicking it too fast.
Oh, whoop.
One, two.
What the fuck?
There we go.
Throw an enemy near the railing.
I know how to do.
There we go.
Well, how do I stagger him?
Grab and rush him to the... Alright.
Damn, there's so many combos for this, too.
Yay!
Since this is a simulation, it just looks like I'm punching
air.
It looks like I'm skitso from people watching outside.
Oh, X is a ring?
I'm gonna mess you up, creep.
Oh, shit!
go.
All right.
Oh, fuck.
Oh,
there we go.
I did it.
Yay.
Nothing to worry about.
All right, continue to the next... Am I... Did I level up
yet?
hundred still just a little baby maybe died in the
simulation you died in real life
all right give me the next simulation
rush over to the edge okay i got that what's the other one
heavy kick i remember which one's the heavy kick throw an
enemy into another Wait,
wait, wait, wait, I need to rush you over to the edge!
No!
Oh my god, what a ragdoll.
I hate the combat.
Oh, I just want to shoot my gun.
We'll do this another day.
I just...
I got folded.
He fucking slammed down...
Fuck this.
I'm going home.
I don't get out of here.
I didn't talk to her.
Where is she?
Where's Selena?
Oh, hey, I got a newspaper.
I got classified papers.
I don't get out of the simulation.
I want to leave.
Do I have to?
Oh, my God.
Am I forced to do?
I think they might.
I think I am.
You're like, you're not getting out of the simulation.
Yeah.
oh my god are they actually gonna make me oh my god there's
no way
is it exit to menu
is it does that take me out
okay store oh it does oh so tactical simulation is outside
of the main game I see I got out of the matrix guys I was
looking for you too Monroe I have your cover story from Q
that's interesting later mate any idea what's in store for
me no clue something dashing no doubt this guy 98.2%
inflation adventurer archaeologist I feel like you should be
able to I hear you got banned from the art club on your
first visit I feel like you should be able to exit in the
tax simulator back to the story of course he is wait no my
captains am I not allowed to wear my captain outfit here
what are we looking at portable airbag shelter sphere if
you're ever caught in an avalanche you'll be glad to be
packing one of these why would I be caught in an avalanche
carrying a gentleman's briefcase we sad oh mind your own
business bond moving on I can't wear my cool-ass captain
outfit.
No, no, no, no, nothing.
Look, you live in a 25,000 pound a year broom closet.
I say get a cat and count your blessings.
Anyway, increased stability.
Gyroscopes.
You think you're up for the task, Jeremy?
I...
Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
I'll put myself together.
Aww.
Steady as a...
Well, not this drone.
A lame joke.
That's sad.
He lost his girlfriend and then she's like, get a cat.
Are you guys testing any new gadgets?
Any new gadgets, guys?
Any new fun toys for me to play around with?
Test number five.
Boyle from accounting.
This is Boyle from accounting.
That is I.
Whoa!
That does sound like Boyle from accounting.
Shooting range instructor.
My name is Waters.
And I treat everybody like an inconvenience.
Okay.
Great word.
Sounds just like Boyle, though.
That's pretty cool.
Now that's a voice changer, guys.
Almost as good as mine.
Just gave her a fresh coat of paint.
Ah.
James.
Go on, Avaganda.
uh i'm here sorry just trying to get through let's see what
did i do what are what are whoa wow okay congealment is
nearly instantaneous but we need to drastically reduce mass
to make the device portable target specs are 56 grams same
as a tennis ball i like that they added like a lot of
exploration around makes you want to explore like around
your surroundings and stuff i really like easter eggs and
references to the gadgets right it's the latest in
non-lethal defense tech not lethal what's the point ultra
fast hardening riot firm that'll pacify an elephant you can
set it off on a timer with it just makes the world much more
immersive a lot world building it feels like a warm hug i'll
take your wife for it really cool you found something in
deep storage oh my god
A minibar?
One silk cushions.
Is it a lifeboat or a love nest?
One doesn't necessarily exclude the other, I suppose.
The past is a foreign country.
What other stuff is there?
Oh my gosh, the bike!
I must be allowed to use this later.
Oh, yay!
Careful with that.
If you value your eyebrows.
Oh, I was about to stand in front of it just to see...
What's this?
What is this?
Whoa, whoa, excuse me.
Oh, her iPads disappeared.
Oh, oh, I should see.
Good eye.
On a car.
Looks can be deceiving.
It's not a car.
I can neither confirm nor deny that.
Never mind.
So what's wrong with an airbag?
Why have hamburger when you can have a steak?
Fair enough.
Damn, that's true.
Oh, they're like, Well, now that the gadget's gone, I guess
my job's done.
Can clock out now.
The day's over.
Have you spoken to the Valhalla?
Anything seemed familiar?
Oh, I thought that was you.
That's brilliant.
Right?
The technology is incredible.
I can't even tell the difference.
And you're not the slightest bit worried that the SIS now
owns your voice for all perpetuity?
It's for science.
Besides, they have all our voices on file.
They what?
Everything you say in Q branch gets recorded, love.
read your contract not the fine print actually it was
emblazoned across page two in bold red letters rub it in why
don't you i guess like you're walking working for a secret
organized secret spy agency you can't really have a lawyer
to look through your contract so it's easier to get him you
know because like what about your like who are you gonna how
are you gonna be able to read through your contract with a
lawyer there so you have to read it yourself
All right, let's talk to Q
A spy lawyer where are you gonna find a spy lawyer back
right?
We just brought it out from storage Cold War legacy piece
phone rings Target enters takes the call the door seals and
a so I guess have your lawyer sign an NDA Quickly filling
the hermetically sealed booth which quietly descends into
the ground where an extraction team awaits Nice Does it
still work no But it holds a bunch of old coins.
They can also...
Oh.
Good luck to the field.
They're rooting for you.
You can also call your mom.
Waters.
How's business?
Brisk.
Now the rest of the targets have arrived.
Still waiting on a shipment of suppressors, though.
There's a free booth if you want to work on your average.
Lead aboard here I come.
All right, let's go talk to Q.
I'm done exploring.
Wait, can I just leave?
Oh, wait.
That's where Q is.
oh my god it's harry's closet oh sorry i'm just trying to
get through sorry i would close my eyes and accidentally
lost my way
all right oh what is your cue that's nice oh it's like a
one-time lawyer once the lawyer reads the contract you kill
him and attention to detail cut proportion and style in
perfect harmony looks a bit big oh no this is for uh monroe
you'll be wearing that one i'm a chauffeur i'm a chauffeur
well don't look at me i just work here if anything i look
more posh than monroe i'm heading over to gadget testing
join me when you're ready there's some new field gear that
i'd like you to try out just because i don't i can get the
accent probably a new line of air freshness my accent's
coming in starting to get more posh oh my god it's the
dagger shoe this is kingsman so looks can kill wait that's
in kingsman
downing street a nice show the lifestyle magazine print mod
Secretary Stephen Bright is on the cover.
The headline reads, Next Stop Drowning Street.
Perhaps.
Where's the dagger shoes?
You're not playing an undertaker, Nash.
Go with that bottle green corduroy blazer.
I'm a financier, Kingsley.
No electric on.
Suit yourself then.
Hmm.
That asymmetrical silk bias cut dress is nice.
Kingsley, Nash.
Bond.
I can barely make out last night's bruises.
Only the subtle stain of defeat.
Must have missed a spot.
What are your covers?
Keith Bollinger.
Private banker to the rich and famous.
Grace Dufrein.
Career diplomat.
Wait, why is everybody else?
What the fuck?
That's handy.
Just because my parents are dead.
Doesn't mean...
Doesn't mean I can't be posh.
You're hanging on by a thread.
Message received.
I'm the chauffeur!
That's fucked up.
This is discrimination.
What is this fucking class system we have here?
Yeah, everyone has such cool rows.
It's not fair.
My other shirts.
Shun the Nepo, baby.
That's what you get for having dead parents.
Tell Orphan, no Posh.
Let's try to see if there's any, like, Easter eggs.
I keep right...
Oh, well, I reset the thing.
I don't know, actually.
Oh, darling, it's a dream come true.
Let's synchronize our stories.
I'm a big-shot sports agent, and you're a washed-up child
influencer with a massive gambling problem.
I took pity on you.
I'm a high-powered lawyer, and you're a former professional
rugby player.
player with moderate brain damage.
And I'm the chauffeur.
Perhensible grunts soothing somehow.
Pick on someone your own size.
Like James here.
Enjoying yourselves.
Get this.
We're a couple.
Blake and Loretta York.
Married four years.
What did you get, James?
Short end of the stick.
That's what?
Greenway strikes again.
Wouldn't the daughter of the foreign secretary be like super
noticeable?
She's using fake identity?
We'll be very happy together.
See you at the briefing.
the thing about nepo babies is that when everybody knows
like she's literally the daughter of the uk's foreign
secretary like i feel like you can literally just google her
that's what i'm thinking like why is she yeah yeah why would
she have like a secret identity unless she's a unless she's
like a hidden kid chauffeur that's just grand like she's
like what is it called like the um the child born out of
wedlock what is it called there's a term for that yeah she
probably does have a wikipedia page
yeah but of course i wouldn't know like my parents are dead
i have more things to worry about i feel like if you're like
in politics especially you would know that that's the child
of the No.
Yeah.
Love child.
Illegitimate child.
Actually, it could be the illegitimate child or some shit.
I mean, that could work.
Okay.
Let's see what's in store.
Splendid work, Bridget.
I'd say one more round of iteration, and we're ready for
field testing.
That is my assessment as well.
Q?
You mentioned some field gear that needs testing?
Quite right.
Yes.
Over here, please.
Oh, is that my camera?
Wait, I paid for this.
You're giving it to me for free?
Wait a minute.
That's not fair.
I spent my clearance money on this.
You mean I could have got this for free?
Oh, you consented, everybody.
I got hustled.
I really did.
Oh shit!
Great work, Bond.
Okay, next item.
A sleek upgrade to a- Insurance must be great here.
This small scale, lightweight projectile blocks visibility,
leaving an opponent open to attack.
Go on, have a go.
Don't mind if I do.
Alright.
Right.
Throw it at Alpha.
You ready, Alpha?
Ready!
Now, as you can see, the smoke obscures Arthur's vision
causing an acute sense of disorientation oh the benefits
good Arthur quite defenseless you okay there he enjoys it
guys you may choose your that's what he gets for not reading
the fine print we'll sort you out if you have questions
thanks good luck out there bond should have read the fine
print Arthur you thought he was gonna be a scientist but he
got recruited to be a test dummy but you're likely to need
them in the car park uh-huh was that My people skills range
in the bottom third.
Surely not.
All right.
Let me grab that.
This is a gadget cart.
Equip gadgets.
All right.
Kind of choosing blindly here.
Any pointers?
The gadget ready to be assigned.
It's placed in the center of the loadout.
Only assigned at any slot.
Choose slot and press.
Okay.
No hostility.
In these types of situations, discretion not force is
advised.
Duly noted.
Oh, I can't.
We're gonna have three.
Okay.
Dark phone.
Ah.
We'll grab that.
We'll grab the three new items.
Interesting.
Wait.
I don't want the...
I'm taking you off the watch.
I feel like the others are more fun.
Alright, we're ready.
Go to operations.
Alright.
Arthur worked overtime every day as a doctoral student just
for his first gig to be a punching dummy.
He might be an intern.
He's like, guys, I did it.
I got an internship at the MR6.
Guys, oh my, I cannot wait to come out with cool new gadgets
for everybody.
And he's like, all right, Arthur.
Put on the helmet and the goggles.
for money penny i think she's in her pod just through that
door down there and you can't miss her all right go to money
penny's pod all right there six years to get that phd just
to be a test of you
hello again this is one of the new recruits i believe this
is whitlock and i'm bankrupt I'm not gonna say anything.
Who is?
I'm scouting the new window as we speak.
Will do.
I say there's any cool dialogue.
Wait, are they?
Are they...
Oh, I thought they were kissing.
I was gonna be ready.
What the fuck?
Why is there a mannequin in the closet?
I gotta be sure.
Sorry, didn't see you there.
Did not mean to do that.
Brief was finished and handed off to diplomatic relations.
You can close that one.
Good.
And where are we on operations, Barron?
It's good to start something new.
Is that Samson?
Oh.
I was going to say.
Tell me about it.
It looked like Samson TV.
All right, let's go through the door.
I don't want to say there was any cool, interesting
conversations.
Oh, wait.
Sure is.
Greenway obviously considers my driving skills indispensable
now in case we get into a car chase oh yes of course and I
thought it was due to your massive fail last night give them
a rest Kingsley you see a massive fail why is she such a
hating experience we can all benefit from oh my gosh she's
such a Haiti the the fuck?
What did I even do?
Just because my parents are dead.
Have we met?
I don't believe we have.
The name's Bond.
Oh.
James Bond.
So that's you?
Yeah?
For all days working deep underground.
It's gotta take us toll.
Comes with the territory.
And apart from a feeling of time standing still, I really
like it down here.
At least we're not in the tunnels.
That used to be a thing.
The floor's called operations.
What do you do down here?
Whitlock and his team deal with the media.
One thing is secrecy, another subterfusion public belief,
and Alistair is the master of misdirection and half-truths.
You make that sound devious.
It's all for king and country.
I myself am an analyst.
Then we have people handling covers, betting, accounting,
mission support, assets, Hmm.
Out of me, have you?
I was the one handling the media after the Iceland incident.
You did cause a few gray hairs around the place.
I saved the world.
You might want to stay clear of Basil from accounting behind
the lifts.
Basil from accounting?
Wait, he hates me too?
I did.
They'll be fine.
In fact, I think the media attention might have worked in
their favor.
It was really busy.
Ah, good.
You never know which way things go after a staging.
What did I do to Basil?
Running it in all.
Ah, no reason for that on this one.
All good.
All right.
Yeah, what did I do?
Just when you made one little oopsie.
M underestimates 009.
You all do.
Thayer's report was inconclusive.
Why do none of my coworkers like me?
I've been gone for too long to yield reliable data.
There's a 50-50 chance that he's taken.
the truth we need to know what he has we need nothing this
man has to offer what the fuck yes this is just the boon
that em's been looking for to get foreign secretary bright
and his lot off our backs but double oh double and that he's
not talking about me okay manipulate okay thank god i
thought they were also talking about me it's like
everybody's talking about me I was like, oh, thank God.
Not me.
Who is it about me?
I couldn't help but overhear you and Greenway.
Couldn't help yourself is what you mean.
Sounds like there's some history between the two of them.
They serve together as double O's.
Right up until Operation Nightfall.
Go on.
Would that I could.
All right, at least it wasn't about me.
I can leave.
I wonder if they're letting us go on the mission because we
aced the nightclub yesterday they would take sorry just
trying to get through oh yeah oh no no they would take more
than okay I'm sure they've run a Thayer assessment on all of
us before mission sign off then we're objectively good
enough to take on real agent work no need to finish training
then is there don't be stupid as Emma said she needs eyes
everywhere for this mission for more active roles it'll take
a lot more to qualify doesn't mean we should coast on this
one I think we it all focus on internalizing our cover
stories all right i don't know i'll meet basil from
accounting so i said there's something behind the elevator i
don't know they're with me or not but i actually missed an
interaction is there anything back here wait is that basil
from accounting which one were you coming from i've been
doing shorts for a couple of months now no prospect on the
iceland relations Oh, that's Basil from accounting.
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
Could you please identify yourself?
I haven't seen you around here before.
Double O recruit.
James Bond.
Iceland.
That's me.
Oh my god, it is Basil.
Do you care to elaborate, Mr. names Basil Winters.
I'll elaborate.
Iceland, two BT65's 11 personnel units with generators,
scanners, cutters, light Triggs, scramblers, comms, all
vaporized by you.
Right.
Uh, oops.
Keep up the good work, Basil.
Oops.
Oh, that's why he doesn't like me.
Cheek.
Oh, that's like, maybe like $20, Basil.
Can't be that bad, right?
Yeah.
I mean, God, Basil, that's just $20 worth the property.
It's not that bad.
No, it looked like you did do something.
What did I do?
We could just buy it.
We could rebuy it.
More like 20 million, Toki.
It's alright.
We'll just take the funding from the king.
Nice place.
That screen big enough for you.
I don't think the monarchy He needs more money.
About 009.
How did he manage to stay hidden for all those years?
I thought Thayer could get a handle on just about anyone in
the world.
Well, it's not a magic wand, James.
Thayer consumes data on an unprecedented scale, but if you
leave none, you're effectively invisible.
Imagine the focus and dedication it takes to stay off grid
for so long.
Did 009 have help?
Almost certainly.
Some even speculated he was with the cousins.
Why would the Americans hide a UK trade?
you don't have siblings do you what America is involved
recruit ranking you have a widget a widget okay looks like I
kept my place well Greenway hasn't handed in the performance
review for last night you have a mission briefing for me I
do let's get the other recruits in here and I'll show you my
god America's with the bad guys you ain't our spy now I mean
they're known to poach other people's scientists and spies
I'm not surprised just remember where some of the top
American scientists came from after a certain war you guys
remember how the nuclear bomb was made
championship match.
No comms, no tracking, no backup.
And these are only the safeguards that we know about.
009 will employ every manner.
Yeah, that's how it's how it's how it's how we had to get
the space.
Which makes you ideally suited for undercover work.
Locate 009 and keep him under close Doki, we had to win the
space wars.
This is a black tag operation.
so discretion ladies and gentlemen is critical
all right here we go no distractions
what happens if i oh they won't let me drive into the forest
guys now i could get used to this wait which side is the
left which which side was the british side and which side is
the american inside on driving it's been too long since i
drove isn't british this side the assignment doesn't live up
to your grand expectations so i'm playing forza if 009 slips
through our fingers you're the last line of defense
exhilarator greenway's testing you may hassle don't give him
an excuse the cap looks good on you though really brings out
your cheekbones Oh, if I drive and then...
Oh, yeah, I'm the chauffeur right now.
Oh, my God.
I'm such a good chauffeur.
You're going to have to up ahead, James.
But what if I don't?
Just a frog in my throat.
Can I just keep driving?
What if I just miss it?
Miss it?
Where will it take me?
Oh, the sheep crossing.
Of course.
They're like, the sheep are here.
All right.
I guess I'll take my right now.
All right, here I am in Slovakia.
Doki proofed it.
Is everything in order?
Routine inspection, man.
Won't be a moment.
All cleared.
Please proceed.
All right.
you
think if i sold a kidney i could afford to stay for a night
i think i have stayed here i mean a wedding back in 22 night
doesn't sound like something you'd forget well the hen was
in can so we flew in by private jet it's dark and we've been
drinking so nice 10 out of 10 i can break the lights darling
nothing at all i have to be sure can i break this what do
you make of double He was the best in his day.
That was a long time ago.
My guess is he's tired of running.
Greenway thinks we're being played.
And since when do you trust Greenway?
I never said I did.
They knew each other, though.
That much is clear.
Something to do with an operation called Nightfall.
And begs the question, did 009 pick Greenway out of good
faith?
Or bad blood?
Well, we're about to find out.
Wait, there's people over there.
Nate, what's the hold up?
Right.
Sounded out for a moment.
Don't make me come up.
I can't unlucky.
I can't drive up the stairs.
I'm limit testing the game, guys.
I'm just...
9 out of 10.
I can't drive up the stairs.
Oh, they knew.
They like he added an invisible wall.
They're new.
The intrusive thoughts we're going to kick in.
What are you doing?
These are the strongest cones in all of Britain.
Oh, my God.
These fucking traffic cones are built out of steel.
The hotel is back in that direction.
Flip here now.
If you're trying to break character, you're doing a cracking
job.
It's my first day at a job.
We did it.
We made it to the hotel.
Switch to comms.
Monroe with me.
James.
Stay.
Save the world some other time, yeah?
Afternoon.
Invitation, please.
Blake and Loretta York.
Plus the help.
Mm-hmm.
Welcome to the Grand Carpathian.
Parking is right up ahead.
Mr. and Mrs. York.
It's okay.
They're rich.
They can rebuild the lights.
Oh, they will.
a penny to them.
We're entering the premises.
Team status?
Nash.
Delivery area.
In position.
See.
Staff quarters.
Ronson.
Conference wing.
Kingsley.
First floor suites.
Bond.
Parking.
I'm parking.
Car park.
In position.
Greenway.
Grand Hall.
comms as instructed.
Keep a low profile and don't let your guards down.
009 most certainly won't.
Out.
I hate my job.
He's just like I hate my job.
I was just regretting my life choices in that car.
How did I get here?
Keep a low profile.
Start smashing lampoes.
That's pretty weird.
That's pretty suspicious.
How would they know I'm a valet?
No harm in stretching my legs.
Bond reporting suspicious behavior.
009?
No.
One of the hotel staff.
Strangest looking bellhop I ever saw.
When I want to see what's in the suitcase, though, Are you
joking?
What are we?
The local tourist board?
I guess he had to be there.
It was odd.
I'm going to check it out.
You will not.
009 is our only priority.
Stay at your post, James.
That's an order.
Yes, Mom.
I guess that would just look like a regular hotel staff
versus a chauffeur.
You're on my way, my friend.
Oops, sorry.
I didn't see you there.
My bad.
I want to check where he dumped.
Investigate the boat, man.
Can I actually go down?
No, it was just grabbing stuff.
It's grabbing more.
Just refueling.
I can't run or look too suspicious.
I guess only spies run.
What's this?
Oh, just some water.
All right.
Sorry, I couldn't see you there.
Well, they say Gretchen Wong were a pair of augmented
reality contacts at the Rapid and Blitz.
The visual feed was hooked up to a chess AI running
thousands of real-time simulations.
Kind of brilliant.
was any of these ever proven in the court of the public
opinion so how is this wonk still competing what are you
talking about what are you even talking about pardon me need
to see a man about a bag where is he missed him oh is he
inside infiltrate the hotel afternoon sir staff and press
only where's staff forgot my press badge you're not need a
way to convince this chap oh convinced him I need a way to
convince him let me just stick this dart in it real quick
convincing done you you're not meant to be here I'm not
comply here we are what's over there there.
Pull it together.
I don't have enough.
Wait, I wonder what's down, what is that over there?
Is that also another?
Wait, I could grab more.
Oh, now I can run.
I need to refuel.
Oh, I'm clearly in the way.
Yep.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
Move away.
Get out of the way.
I don't know.
I just want to know what that is.
He's like hiding something from behind.
Wait,
later.
Oh, I guess it's from one of my equipment.
Alright.
Why are you still here?
Easy now.
I'm leaving.
it's over there no he's not sick no more i've told you to
leave oh i should have made him i should have made you sick
oh yeah but what if there's water huh
what's up with that oh my gosh i made him sick and then go
oh my god what is that no
you've run out of chances
What if I keep putting water?
I just want to know what he's hiding over there.
What is that?
I sure made the other guy sick.
Wait, maybe I can get behind him.
Okay.
Don't break on me again.
We have an idea.
What if I be like?
What the?
Do I need to get physical?
No, I was just leaving.
I'll regret.
I'm leaving.
Don't worry.
You're this close.
Oh yeah, how close?
That's you.
I just...
No, I don't have enough.
I don't know where I'm gonna get more toxic shit.
Not only there's anymore I'm sad I don't have any more toxic
shit wait I'll use drop
what's she talking about George yeah it's no use I met with
the whistleblower claims to have proof that Nivex cheating
but they'll only talk to Hoffman how far off is he well tell
him to floor it or we'll lose the scoop of the year I I
stashed his press badge inside one of the big pots on the
lower ramparts.
Oh, it was just more ways to get press badge.
Oh, there's multiple ways for the press badge.
Oh, I see.
Well, now that I know that, all I did was just...
I can't believe that worked.
I poisoned that guy and then I went and grabbed the press
badge.
That's that easy.
I need to catch up with that bellhop.
Show me your ID and it's good.
I don't know quite the security setup you've got here right
I didn't brute force it I was a genius I was a brilliant spy
nothing gets past them I feel more secure already that's
looking right that bellhopper just went through do you know
him no but I've only been it wasn't brute force was planned
by Doki the best spy in MI6 double O Doki all right checks
out Step into the scanner, please.
This ingenious spy skills.
Member of the press.
So what my badge says.
Continue up the stairs, please.
The mezzanine is great for photos.
Best view in all the house.
Good tip.
But it's great.
I like how they're like the best security.
And literally just went in there and was like, Noink.
You won't be needing that.
Please.
Yeah, I corrected
Lawson.
You know where it leads.
Imagine if the hotel owner caught you down there.
Besides, I couldn't find a locking mechanism.
So you did try.
If that collection ever gets raided, I'm looking in your
direction.
I'm not really a wine person.
No, but are you
Jambo Rouge in his vault?
I hear he also own a 1796 Costa Fiera, but that has to be a
rumor.
Okay.
Let me stop you right there.
bets to lay later see you at romana's birthday party how do
i get invited i like listen to the dialogue in this game y
'all like really unique and interesting blocked nothing
gets past the scanners these yeah don't mind me ladies
nothing get past the scanners guys it's like i hope it's I
hope the airport's not like this.
If a terrorist can just go, yoink, I'm depressed now.
I don't think I'll trust the airport a lot.
He's getting an extra mint on his pillow.
That's for sure.
Cholana.
She's fucking the hotel guest.
Damn, that's spicy.
That's a fantasy right there.
I don't know, but I love how the dialogue in this game
Because it's like they're all in there It's like they're all
in their own little world It really adds to the world
building Like they're all like their own character
Wow Did you hear the music?
Let's see what all the fuss is about There was like Boom,
boom They had a little Oh wait, are they watching chess
Hopefully I'm the last thing on his mind the music was like
a little james bond like but like slow down um okay um um um
over it's like a hint of james bond music i literally
have no idea nerds i'm surrounded by them
Not damn nerds.
Let's not get spotted just you.
Why am I not surprised?
Kingsley, you can keep a secret, can't you?
Don't bother.
Better not get spotted.
Walk straight to her.
Look, I'm onto something.
this is my shot at proving myself to green wage help me out
here wow this is unprofessional even for you command bond
has abandoned his post repeat bond has abandoned his post
copy i will handle it proceed bad form kingsley nice knowing
you what the fuck they're only the uk's most successful ai
company they pretty much she's so mean to me yeah she's so
into me guys I hope you drop the drink.
I hope you drop your fucking drink.
I hope you drop it.
Fucking rat.
Frame zero snitch.
I know!
You didn't even hesitate.
This guy better be worth it.
I don't see if there's any interesting extra bonus stuff.
Where have I seen him before?
I think he models for all except...
I should have just told her about my mission.
I don't think she snitched on me.
Fucking rat.
It's like nobody likes her.
I bet she, like, tells teacher when she forgets about the
homework.
I mean, like, teacher.
Oh.
Distracted.
You distracted?
doink I don't think you'll be needing that well now I have a
staff key you
know mr.
Prendergast the author yeah she was a hamod or some shit
claims a better worse than this tell mr.
Vargas if you see him Prendergast is down in reception
demanding to see the manager wouldn't want to keep mr.
Prendergast waiting okay something doing mr.
Prendergast
It's over there Now, why do you go this way?
Well, I never well, I never Norman are you listening to me?
Oh, whoops, sorry, let me That was like am I eavesdropping
next to it?
I wonder about the homework Mrs. Smith?
Fucking Kingsley.
What happened?
Well, I called him three times and he just rushed past me.
Ignored me completely.
Disgraceful When was this incident just a moment ago?
Hurry up.
You might catch him Oh wait, did you happen to see where he
went?
I'll tell you exactly where he went towards reception
reception You've been most helpful mom.
I'll take it from here.
You better.
Where is the reception?
Oh, it's down here.
Can I jump?
Oh, I have to go this way I have more stuff to eavesdrop
Wait, I want to eavesdrop.
I want to listen to everything.
That's what I call a trophy.
Should have been a chess piece.
Is that chess piece made of diamond?
Holy shit.
It's Russian actually.
From the court of Tsar Alexander III, if I'm not mistaken.
Actually.
At least someone knows what they're talking about.
Are you some kind of an art historian?
Cat burglar.
Just don't tell anyone.
Wouldn't want to cause a scene.
That's right.
Who was that?
I'm actually...
I want to watch this.
Let's watch this super intense chess scheme right now.
Let's blow his cover too.
I'll explore later.
Oh, I can't.
Imagine if I could just blow his cover.
I want to explore now!
But there's something over here.
Gretchen Wan versus Alexander Nevik.
You guys, can you tell who's going to win?
2,600, 2,800 chest rating.
Hey, you look like you've seen a ghost.
Hello, Earth to Ralphie.
Is he okay?
How do I eavesdrop this?
Oh, here.
I'm guessing I'd not, I don't get punished for just walking
around them trying to eavesdrop.
From that anti-book over there.
Shot me a look like talk and you're dead and liked it why
would the blonde man tear up a book i'm sure mike was only
trying to scare you ralph yeah well he bloody succeeded
nothing that a stiff drink won't fix i'll fetch you a gnt
careful sorry who's winning oh my god it's on twitch guys
they're streaming on twitch.tv slash chess what's this one
of pages has been torn up I just told your colleague, stay
clear of the backstage area.
This is the world championships for pity's sake.
I need to focus.
Dreadfully, sorry.
Won't be a moment.
Whoops.
This bellhop.
Did you see where he went?
Reception.
He took off towards the reception.
Good man.
What?
Starting letter.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, yeah, I got badge.
Okay, there is one more...
Why do I talk to him?
I talk to him again?
Why are you still highlighted?
You have anything else to talk about?
Give me a break, mate.
Oh, why are you still highlighted?
I don't know.
You were highlighted.
Alright, fine.
I won't talk to you anymore, unless...
He doesn't want to talk to me anymore.
Okay, there should be one more eavesdrop.
I just like hearing what they all have to say.
It's like he doesn't know he's highlighted.
I know!
How does he not know he's highlighted right now?
Spoke with an accent.
All right, let's talk to...
Oh, I have a staff key.
Hey, guys.
Where did you come from?
I'm a penetration tester with rhinestone insurance, and I
just discovered three direct violations.
I need a word with your manager now.
Yes, of course.
Good lad.
Sorry, this is shop talk, sir.
Oh, don't mind me.
Don't mind me.
Bit of curiosity, never hurt anyone.
or how do i eavesdrop this
oh here one of the bellhops is a no-show didn't even call in
sick he's so fired at least the temp agency is fast they
sent a replacement already tall blonde guy right i just ran
into him in the laundry see like the most famous bellhop in
the world strange accent though Well, the blonde man is
known bellhop.
That's for sure.
Time to do the laundry.
Stop.
Let's see.
Male, Caucasian, whitish blonde hair.
It's still easier.
Six foot two.
Spoke with an accent.
Must be a foreign national.
I'm sorry, Mr. Prendergast.
But we simply do not have a bellhop of that description.
Ridiculous.
And who made off with my back then?
I demand to see the manager.
He is on his way, Mr. Prendergast.
I'm sure it's all a misunderstanding.
It better be.
I'll be over here.
All right.
We need to find the laundry now.
Where is the laundry?
I guess it's over there.
I'll go feel... Oh, hey guys.
Can you believe it?
Grab this.
Why not?
Everybody cheats.
Wait, who's cheating?
Does he has...
Does he have the...
The butt vibe reader?
Is that what he's using?
Did increased security will be changing the codes on date.
The codes are stored in the manager's office behind the
reception.
All right.
Oh, my God.
He's using the butt vibrator.
Can I be of assistance, sir?
Did someone rob that gentleman?
A misunderstanding with one of our temps.
That's all.
A bellhop.
Tall, white blonde hair.
My.
He is certainly popular today.
The hidden tech.
For those who don't know, there was a chess game.
What's his name?
One of the best chess players in the world.
And people were saying he's cheating.
He has a vibrator in his butt.
Where it would vibrate him to tell him what move to make
next.
It was the butt vibrator controversy.
I forgot the guy's name.
But he's really famous.
And he's signed to an esport team.
busy day fully booked as always we're not the region's
favorite romantic gateway for nothing like he's clearly has
it you insert chess i'm more of a snooker girl say yeah he
was they were saying that he was yeah magnus carlson yeah
they're saying that magnus had a vibrating butt plug that
was vibrating via morse code to tell him how to how to do
his next move
A Grandmaster and a chess champion called him out on it.
He's like, you clearly have a vibrator in your ass right
now.
And they're like, I know it.
Everyone else was like, what the fuck?
Oh, I don't have a cellar key.
Whoops.
I might have fucking...
made her sick for no reason my bad was it not Magnus who was
it who accused who oh yeah it was his opponent sorry his
opponent yeah he
said it was behind the reception but I don't know where it
is
okay let's see okay the blob now seeing entering the
basement i guess we'll spot it here's the list of passcode
oh here okay
uh he may he may what he may what okay let me find the
management office where is the man oh it's all the way here
uh you can't be here i'm left hotel security any reports of
pickpocketing in this guests who've been relieved of their
jewelry some people have no shame hope you catch them that's
the plan can i open this door well i guess i can be here
the 1917 rogue is crucified but pelts in comparison to the
monk eris sacramento superb oh that's a safe not what eight
one eight oh five 1805 1805 battle of Trafalgar easy oh it's
on the other side nothing whoops it's just that easy guys
what's this two zero zero five oh wait is that the passcode
why is it 2008 sorry a 2008 wine in there 1952 2005 2014 i
think any of that makes the safe code never seen the hotel
so busy before i know the safe code is boobs i mean let's
try it what was it 2008 this wasn't 2008 uh what was the
other one let's say that's not that vintage 1952
oh there we go i mean wow uh all right oh and i get the
cellar key nice
really what can i do in the cellar seeing entering the
basement laundry all right not very uh great at the whole
stealth thing part sorry sir step only please excuse me
health inspector we've received just a health inspector guys
anything i can do yes if you see any way as long as i'm
confident no one will know see guys confidence is key
all right i do that and then i go straight in she'll never
know and then bam hello guys that will do it
most of the laundry workers are ex-cons that easy they're
sweethearts once you get to know them yeah i'm not going
down there without an entourage fine i'll take the laundry
duty but seriously you've got the wrong idea they bet barely
even fight barely it's the head chef you got to worry about
talk about living breathing
stereotype oh i can't talk to her anymore was that it she
doesn't want to talk to me oh huh well i don't want to talk
to you either that's fine i i didn't even want to talk to
you too
to be like oh make sure no one follows you got it friend
it's trying to be polite let her finish your conversation
that's crazy what are we looking for you know with all that
money in my face According to Orlando, the Sun will break
the death cycle.
Better check that.
Come out now and show your face.
Well, guess I showed my face.
I guess it's okay now.
But you did say, come out now and show your face.
I didn't lie.
What's over here?
Oh, it's locked.
But he asked me to show my face!
I wonder, do you think they see me all the way over it?
I think everything's fine.
There we go.
See, everything is fine.
Huh?
Excuse me.
Are you in the right way?
What's up with you?
Hello.
What happened?
Um...
Take it easy.
I don't want any trouble.
Everything's fine.
See, nothing to worry about.
Where?
He's up with this shit.
Hmm.
Uh...
I'll make him sick.
Oh, shit!
How did he see me?
It's okay.
What was that?
Situation contained.
It has been contained.
Everything has been contained.
All right.
What?
What happened to them?
Hello.
I'm waiting.
Explain yourself.
What for him?
Oh, I think he was already having a bad day before I got
here.
Yeah.
I will take over it from here.
Move back.
Good man.
Okay.
And
it's been contained.
Gone again.
It's that easy.
Guys.
And it's that easy.
A worn bellhop outfit.
Size XL.
Double D's done it again.
Situation.
Contained.
Smooth as hell.
Alright.
grabs this and we got the laundry bag change the skies wait
somebody's over there yeah I see it let's grab some bats
I guess I kick it I have to there's nobody here okay that's
good it's a little worried Everybody's just hanging out.
Cressida, I'm back at my post.
Really?
Really.
I'm in full view of the car park.
Good.
Let's keep it that way.
Stay vigilant.
You're the boss.
I get out of there.
Oh!
Must have taken the scenic route.
See?
No one's in here.
Silent alarm didn't trigger itself.
Check the windows.
Hey, Laszlo, look at that.
Yeah, I see it.
What the hell?
Hey, little warning next time.
Contained.
What the hell was that?
You look like shit.
Look at that.
Look at life!
I, uh...
Look alive!
Everything's been contained.
You okay, my friend?
He's knocked into a coma.
Sorry, fellas.
Desperate measures.
Wait, can I lure him?
Psst.
Get over here in the corner.
Oi!
Look out.
Come on.
Oh, shit.
I used it up.
I used it all up.
Oh, I did not mean to use it up.
Come on.
Get near the pile of body.
I know you want to Oh, whatever I wanted to add you to the
body collection But that's good enough too That also works
Oi Oi, mate Unlucky, I couldn't lure him in I grabbed this I
wonder what does that I guess I can like take a picture of
the That's right Move along folks Oh hey.
Oh hey.
Monroe, I need your help.
Took you long enough.
The blonde man.
He's changed his disguise.
I knew he was up to something.
Yeah?
How'd you know he's not a thief?
He doesn't move like a thief.
He moves like a soldier.
I'm telling you.
Something's not right.
Look.
I might have seen a bloke who fit the bill.
Tall, blonde.
Only he was in a suit.
Went by the name of Locke.
Where was this?
Over at reception.
A little while ago.
He was heading upstairs.
Thanks, mate.
Hey.
didn't hear it from me are upstairs too bad search
investigate the blonde man okay oh i hear him that's him i
knew it i heard the i heard the russian slash Slavician
accent slash Serbian accent, whichever one.
Blonde fellow.
You want me to check up on him?
Nah, it can wait.
They're probably going over security features.
That chest trophy is worth the fortune.
Room 206.
Oh, they're trying to...
That has to be it.
Okay.
206.
You're so worried about Ezra's interview, can't you, you
know, grease the wheels a little?
Donate a wing?
Or at least some new outfits for the rowing?
team god knows they need them i mean hello the naughty's
called they want their neo preppy look back what if i could
but in these times everything's so transparent now the last
thing we need is another school of it as if tim's mosco ties
weren't bad enough no oh that's the awkward yeah well i can
feel for him the competition is tough i was king of the
world at seven oaks but going to uni was a wake-up call
suddenly i was up against the best of the best not to
mention the best of the worst and must suck to be so wealthy
while you're hard problems okay 206 by the way how do i get
over there i guess i have to make him sick so i need to find
more
i'm staff i guess i'm not staff i've got to find a way to
fool this You see that?
You don't want to fix that?
Oh my god.
Fucking use the wrong thing.
Okay, at least there's...
What the fuck?
Why is this block here?
Oh, I got 205.
Oh, I can eavesdrop!
What?
What if I make him sick, though?
That was spooky.
Hey, 205.
I guess it's just that easy.
Anything I can take?
I mean, nobody's here.
A lurid message scribbled on the back.
complete white lipstick mark sweet 205 and 5 miss husband is
watching the game oh they're inside aren't they what hello
pardon me mom didn't think anyone was in I'm with management
one of our guests lost his pet anaconda we're going floor by
floor well it's not down here I'll take your word for it go
on then shut the door on your way out right damn okay before
i i just want to make sure is there anything else i can
steal in her room oh nice you want to all right let's go all
right don't worry your lover will be here soon while you
cheat on your husband i guess unusual just the usual things
rich people do
Oh.
Alright.
Whoa.
I'm in 206.
It's a mess.
Stay on the line.
I'll have a look around.
This should be good.
Security protocol for the hotel.
Oh, they scouted this hotel.
Why did they trash it?
It's in here.
Nothing.
Good fit for a body.
Oh, is there a dead body here?
Maybe it's in this room.
drawer or wardrobe nope just a phone in the bathtub oh no
bodies found a wall suit size XL this guy changed his
disguise again again he changed his outfit small word big
difference okay how many disguises did he bring because the
hotel stamp.
The leading story appears to be about the mysterious death
of famous climate scientists in Orlando, Florida.
Another one!
Did you hear about that?
A bunch of American scientists are dying, like mysteriously
assassinated.
I found a key card holder.
No, a joke anymore.
Could mean anything, mate.
Don't jump to college.
Oh my god.
Monroe, this isn't some party that got out of hand.
These are signs of a struggle.
And someone put up one hell of a fight.
If that's You're not supposed to say that part out loud.
Doki, they're gonna get you now.
Doki, don't stand next to a window, Doki.
It must have been though.
So weird, so weird that they all mysteriously passed away,
guys.
From like a heart attack or something.
Bond predicted the future.
I found the chief of security's wallet.
It's full of cash.
Doesn't look like a robbery.
He might have dropped it.
In the fireplace.
Monroe, this is serious.
the blonde man did something to the chief of security i'm
sure of it okay so why and how is this connected to 009 not
a clue yet call you back answer the door housekeeping oh
that's not suspicious at all every time yeah it just got a
little angry
Oh, that's him.
Anyone else feel that?
Sing, talk to me.
I'm picking up some chatter about a power surge in the
electrical room.
It crashed the security system, but there doesn't appear to
be any permanent damage.
Nothing to indicate foul play.
All right.
Keep an eye on it.
Everyone else, step up your search.
Monroe, listen to me.
The blonde man, a missing security chief, the power surge,
009.
Somehow it's all connected.
What's his game?
I don't know, but Greenway said 009 is a master manipulator.
If he knew what we know, he'd pull the plug for sure.
I'll look into it.
Where are you now?
Back in the blonde man's trail.
Is that 009?
Where's he working on their 009?
Got to go behind the scenes.
Yeah, I'm tracking Agent 47.
Yeah, this is the Agent 47 crossover right now.
That's how he's changing disguises so fast.
Vaughn versus Agent 47.
Collab of the Century.
Who will win?
Yeah.
I've quoted a red flag.
It's only a few minutes.
What's the worst that could happen?
According to the logs, someone went inside.
That was seven versus 47.
Must be the security team.
Who will win?
security chief's key card was missing this is starting to
add up okay but to follow where this leads
that's him now what's in those crates
oh my god there's 20 conversations happening right now
Too many conversations, too many life stories to listen to.
You must have gone down this way.
What happened?
I was on a shift at the delivery gate and suddenly, bam,
cold sweats, stomach cramp.
Belly made it back to the toilet.
Thanks for that.
Yeah, see, this is why I never touched the shrimp buffet.
You want me to call you a replacement?
I'm good.
thanks this new guy big tall fella with a white blonde head
he took over from me oh wait he also has the spy gear must
be one of the attempts wait is that actually maybe that's
double nine wait he also has a nausea spray the dart phone
there gotta hurry bond your hunch was right not again
stuffed inside a laundry cart in the basement and you were
Bro, the blonde man smuggled something in on a truck while
the security scanners were down.
How can I be expecting something heavy?
Oh, this is bad.
I'll inform Cressida.
Don't let this guy out of your sight.
I gotta make sure I have everything equipped.
All my gadgets equipped.
Oh.
Don't do this to me, you piece of...
What if I do it again?
Oh.
What would...
Whoa!
Oh, that's all me.
Yeah, see, it was his fault.
Guess he'll have to quit, guys.
I guess they're a little behind schedule on the food.
Not his plate stokey!
He spent an hour making those!
You made him quit!
He was just here.
Went into the staff area.
Didn't see him.
Why?
Nothing.
I just...
I could have sworn I saw a bellhop who looked just like him.
Maybe he's doing double shifts.
Maybe it's his twin.
You don't know that.
You don't know his life story.
What?
Ah, that's...
You again.
Weird.
That's right.
The maid is picking a lock.
Now you've seen everything.
Is that my bond girl?
Oh my god!
Guys!
was close my bond girl she's here just making sure the
plates are broken in joshua thank you the super chat thank
you thank oh my god james whatever you think you're doing
star oh la la never forget your first bond girl get back to
you knew it there was something in those crates
Bye.
Yeah, but I know parkour.
Don't worry, I'm faster than an elevator.
Okay, a door blocked me.
Missed him again.
I can't see we go that way.
I'm not faster than an elevator.
I don't think I've tried it before.
Is it your own concoction?
I can't take credit, I'm afraid.
The hotel owner has a huge collection of mixology books and
books.
Alright, she has to have gone this way.
So let me slowly walk across the chest place.
I'm getting...
I'm down in front.
Who said that?
Huh?
That's fucking right.
right now you can't watch shit i'd say it to my fucking face
next time you fucking snob this was much more important
impossible how could he have gotten away i i was just right
behind him how could he have had that much time to get away
why am i supposed to investigate here gee i wonder see
anything oh unless it's always this passage of course six
dials take more than blind luck okay oh let's see I mean,
there's a chimera.
Yeah.
It's a chimera, right?
Nothing to it.
Easy.
Look at bringing up the lobster.
I guess it did.
Yeah, I feel like it was not the lobster.
She wouldn't listen.
Engage.
Break cover if you need to.
I don't know about this.
Damn it, Monroe.
There's no time to wait for permission.
We need to act now.
This is the last time I'm saving your ass.
Oh, that's me.
I was like, I got him now.
The Lord ain't just entered reception.
Heading straight for the Grand Hall.
That was me.
I didn't recognize myself in the reflection.
I see him.
Everyone repositioned.
cover the exits.
Monroe, what's your status?
Monroe, copy.
He's busy.
Cressida, you need to call it off.
Something bad's about to happen.
James, what have you done?
Where's Monroe?
Almost there.
Monroe?
I
fucking knew it.
I fucking knew it.
I was like, I'm bonding I fucking knew it.
Well, I was toky right behind the rail.
I've cursed him.
I've cursed.
I was like, oh, he hates me, but I know we're going to start
becoming best friends.
And then he's going to fucking die.
And then he becomes my character.
Oh.
Why did you do this to him?
Not my doomed yaoi!
I promise, this won't end well for you.
I think it won't end well for me, not gonna lie.
That's fucking right!
That's right!
This is for Monroe!
This is for my bro!
That's fucking right!
A bomb?
Oh.
I should do a little of that too.
For my bro!
God too soon!
What the fuck?
He has a partner too?
It's not fair!
I would have had- Oh, they're twins.
That's how they change so fast.
I had a mon- you have a mon- row as well?
Oh shit.
Must be nice!
Okay.
Oh shit!
Oh my god.
My god, there's too many!
That's right for Monroe!
Okay.
He's finished?
Too too many.
That's right, I have a sword now.
Oh, I mean, my sword's bigger.
Oh, they have to go where the bomb will explode.
He's finished.
Alright, cut.
You always cut the red wire.
You know, we'll do the motherboard.
Oh.
I guess the battery.
See the red wire.
Come on, which one?
Red!
Oh, green!
There we go.
It's always the green wire.
Monroe!
Oh, shit!
Double-07 seconds.
But I stopped the bomb, though.
There was a second bomb!
If Monroe was alive, he would have got the second bomb.
The bomb also has a twin.
Monroe!
We were supposed to be spies together!
We're gonna live forever!
I knew they were gonna kill him off.
good to be true it was too fucking good to be true having a
brother from another mother he wasn't allowed to be happy oh
my god does she die too of course she doesn't fucking die
you're gonna kill my bro you might as well kill her too
james i don't feel like which way did he go i plucked hell
for a second and the son of a Oh, of course, it was a bloody
suicide mission.
He used himself as bait to get to me.
And now, there, that's him.
Is he the bad guy?
What if he's the bad guy?
I don't know, the prize, James.
Oh, my God.
Now she can't be a spy, dude.
They don't even give her, they don't even kill her off.
They make her fucking, they make her paraplegic.
They're putting her in a wheelchair so she'll never be, so
she'll never be able to follow her dreams.
That's fucked.
That's actually more, that's, that's more fucked.
Just would be allowed seeing me be successful.
Bitch.
Sorry.
That's what she gets for not liking my cool poster, I guess.
Looking for these?
For God.
Hold on.
Whoa.
Just who the hell are you?
Not now.
Oh,
now I can drive downstairs.
That's the car.
I can't believe it.
Careful what you wish for.
Alright, let me go.
This is my Forza.
smooth oh my god now my childhood friends once dead and the
others in the wheelchair now I have to live on to honor
their names all right nice that's
looking right I'm on your tail I'm almost there
Look at that.
Smooth as hell.
Oh my god, it's the fucking sheep that blocked us last time.
Wait, why is there another...
Oh, that's just the road.
I was like, oh, there's another guy.
Look, there's another car driving in the wheat fields.
But then I realized that was just a car on the road.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I can catch up.
That's right.
He's waiting for me.
Okay, he might be gone, gone.
Left, go left.
What?
What are you doing?
Learn to steer.
Left.
Go left.
Okay, fast.
Watch the road.
Left.
Go left.
Oh, that's not the...
Oh.
I thought that was a road.
It looked like a road.
It looked like...
It looked like Ron left.
It looked like a road.
I didn't realize it was in front of me.
To be fair, that did look like the road, though.
It looked like it was part of it.
I'm just gonna go this way.
There's a shortcut here.
Shortcut.
Thank God you don't drive in real life.
Gus, thank you for super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Not yet.
time for everything all right no we're talking it's okay we
can kill him i guess maybe maybe because closer casino
because because a car cast maybe cast she'll become my like
back girl she'll be like my new money penny or something
maybe she'll be my new handler or maybe q's assistant right
Asian Charlotte Ross I'm with the DGSE that French
intelligence oh my god my bond girls French what's your
interest in 009 Becca didn't spend his fugitive years on a
golf course that's what you think DGSE has been hunting here
for a long time this is the closest we've ever gotten and
I'm not letting him slip through my fingers now sounds like
we have a conflict of interest how about we burn that bridge
when we get to it I'm by me all right Tell the truth, Mint
was your driving teacher, right?
She actually drives.
She drives everywhere.
More like I'm her driving teacher.
Will, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I've been in a car with her driving it.
Well, in that case.
And I'm still alive.
Unless I'm a ghost this entire time.
It's like you've been, it's like I see you.
dead people and I'd find out how much it really goes.
Next, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the day I...
And this is where...
This is my I see dead people moment where I found out I've
been dead all alive.
And everything clicks together.
Yeah, I was like, wait.
Catch the...
Oh, I have a... I have my gun.
I was like, I have a gun?
I'm licensed to kill, so does it really matter?
There we go.
Wait, who shot me?
Are you still alive?
Oh, you're so lucky.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, is it?
Oh, shit.
Okay, give me a sec.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I might be dead.
Bon was killed.
I might have been running into the open there.
I was just like, they said the plane was leaving.
I was just like, oh, shit, let me get there now.
I'm sorry.
I was just listening to instructions.
All right, where's the other guy?
There we go.
Let me grab a gun.
Good soldiers, father, or it is.
Let me grab this, actually.
Bro, I'm trying, but everybody's shooting me!
Oh my god, bro, fuck this guy.
All right.
I'm literally one, so I'm going to wait.
There we go.
Yeah, I see the big red barrels, but it's cooler for me to
shoot.
But...
It's cooler to see me headshot all of them to death.
Oh, I need like...
I think I can...
It's harder with the SMG, for sure.
Oh, actually, this is easier, though.
There we go.
Where is he?
There you go.
It's down to him, guys.
Remember that.
It's down to him.
I guess it didn't work.
There we go.
I had a feeling that was a bomb.
You heard that?
It's down to him.
Coming over.
No!
Grab the hose.
Oh my god.
I'm coming up.
I'm gonna grab it.
Oh shit.
Okay, plan.
I have to do that.
That's looking right.
Oh, it's this way.
Shortcut.
Grab it, James Bond.
Grab it, 007.
Yeah, let me shoot the plane with...
Yep, let me shoot the plane where your agent's at right now.
Yeah, let me just hope it doesn't hit the fuel tank over
there.
It's not very smart.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Okay, but what if I throw you off?
Nice.
Serpentine!
There we go.
Okay.
009.
You're next.
That's right.
I'm fucking trying to find you.
This is a revenge mission now.
Who's that?
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I was gonna say, how am I- where's the takedown?
Planes flying dark.
It's all up to me.
think need a way to force it down think james think okay if
i could access the flight control system oh wait i used to
be a pilot this works let's make some turbulence
oh wait whoops i realized i could have
Wee!
Nice.
Are they all dead?
Oh shit.
Now they are.
Goodbye.
Oh you're going down like that then I guess.
Oh that's, I like that mechanic.
That's fun.
I use the environment for me.
Get a parachute.
Oh my god, I hope I find a parachute.
Does anyone...
What does a parachute look like?
Does any of this look like a parachute?
Um...
This must be a parachute.
That's a gun, right?
Oh, fuck.
I got a gun, though.
No!
Banana!
I need to hit you right!
There we go.
There he is.
Got you.
No, fuck.
Got you!
Yoink!
My parachute now!
There you go.
He has something bad means.
I jumped out of a plane in Savlaki, I guess.
He's got the achievement.
Oh, so that happened.
Monro!
Why did I have to be...
Who cares about the other two?
Three died.
James The service is over I care about Monroe
Sorry to intrude I'm Sir Nicholas Webb AI pioneer National
security advisor and CEO of web industries Monroe I was
going to say I'm sorry for your loss Secretary Bright
informed me of what happened I'm sure you did It was like a
pro to me So much for the secret service.
As the creator of Thayer, I'm privy to certain information.
I know all about your exploits in Iceland.
He's a villain.
I feel like he's the villain.
Most impressive.
Why did you do it?
If I may ask, risk your life on a million to one chance.
Why do I know?
point one out for Monroe this for you bro meaning for you me
for two people really are capable of the most extraordinary
things I spend so much time around machines I sometimes
forget
no rest for the way oh seven double oh seven you're a rare
breed bond I should be interested to see what you do next.
He has to be the villain, man.
Not him.
He's giving villain vibes, too.
You tell me.
Come on.
M wants us back at MI6.
Him and the other...
M and AI, bro, both give me villain vibes.
There's always a twist villain.
Uh, yes?
Yes, sir.
Take a seat.
Hold all calls to my direct line.
These are the facts.
009 is acting on some archaic vendetta against MI6.
His actions have brought us to our knees, and we are in the
midst of a full-blown diplomatic crisis.
This is exactly the kind of cock-up that Foreign Secretary
Bright has been waiting for to shut the program down.
However...
I mean, we literally disabled his kid, so...
makes sense.
He really was okay with the program because his daughter was
in the program.
Now she can't walk anymore.
I mean, it makes sense for him to want to shut it down.
We literally put his kid in the wheelchair.
He is not ready.
I'm perfectly capable of handling this.
You open that for me.
Damn, that's fucked, Jim.
Greenway will take point.
Bond, you will do as your Do what he's told?
That's not the bond way.
Am I being clear?
Perfectly, Mom.
Bond, you go and see Q for your gear and Moneypenny for your
briefing.
You're dismissed.
Happy to help.
Guys, I'm really enjoying this game right now.
I'm so tempted to make our record more James Bond.
I'm sorry, guys.
Don't you have somewhere you need to...
be bond i really want to play more tomorrow it's good it's
so good i'm like i'm really enjoying the story yeah you were
on your way downstairs i'm just really enjoying the story i
want to know what happens next i love i love the story so
far it just feels like i'm watching a bond movie but i'm
actually playing the game too not like some other game out
there yeah not like other other games out there where you're
watch it's just watching a movie yeah
this game actually deserves to actually be the top 20 choice
six game of the year oh what god idea what what are they
talking about
let's see
i think this could be a game of the year contender honestly
a lot of games can be a game of the year contender i'm okay
i think this is better than resident evil requiem at the
moment with like at the moment with the the current stage of
me playing this game i i think this is better in resident
evil requiem it's really fun it's actually really fun i
really i'm enjoying it i like the world building like that
the how each mpc has their own um has his own little story
like more like dialogue so you can learn more about their
life it's really fun just um exploring around um and like
just listening to like what they're saying I love all the
mechanics the mechanics are really fun I know they teach me
how to disarm people but it's just so much easier to
headshot I'm sorry you know how they're like you give us so
many options to disarm shoot them in the legs and stuff and
I'm just going pop pop pop they're just dead it's so it's so
easy to headshot in this game.
Like, I don't have to disarm them or anything.
Only one shot is all it takes.
Yeah.
But Doki, what about the flair?
Yeah, but I'm trying to be efficient.
I'm trying to be efficient here.
Like, I could just kill them.
It's so much fun.
I love James Pipe.
I do have hope for making it up the year contender mixtape.
But Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm an efficient killer I think I I really like this game so
far But I have to I'm gonna call it here, but tomorrow I'm
Um Tomorrow I'm gonna change to my armor core to James Vod
because I actually really want to play more of this game But
I don't want to overdo it today because it's already five.
I've already streamed six hours And I don't want to overdo
it because like I said, I have to Make sure my voice doesn't
get too fucked up by next week.
But we're going to swap Armor Core.
I'm so sorry, Armor Core beat fans.
I'm so sorry.
But I really want to know what's going to happen next.
It's been really fun.
I've really been enjoying this game.
Like, it doesn't even feel like I've been playing.
Yeah, it doesn't even feel like I've been playing for six
hours, too.
But honestly, this is one of my Game of the Year contenders
right now.
this is definitely um game of the year for me um because
i've been enjoying it a lot i really like everything so far
um next thing thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you and enjoying the movie like vibe you might also enjoy
indiana jones in a great circle it's got a similar sort of
vibe thank you for the super chat thank you thank you yeah
i've been wanting to play that game too like there's so many
good games right now and there's like there's so little time
and so many good games
call here everybody because like i said i want to make sure
i don't overdo my streams uh for this weekend um and but i
really really like this game um if you guys want if you guys
want to play yourself i highly encourage you guys to try the
game out yourself as well if you guys like it it's just
really fun that's really all i can say i've been having a
blast playing and just like doing dumb too doing all sorts
of dumb as well around uh in this game um But as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing And if you stay up for me head to
bed guys you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys Bye All right, this time this time guys I will make
sure you guys can see the new doki's added.
I won't forget this time Bye.
Bye, buddy.
Bye.